hello everybody hello hello i had to push back the stream a little bit because um i tried to get my shit together uh because um you know when i missed that flight it was sort of a wake-up call and i came back to really i'm really really moldy ball and i was just like i can't live like this because i was like low-key I was thinking maybe I could just wait until my cleaner comes here and then she can deal with that.
But that's also like in two weeks.
So I was like, I should fix this myself.
I was like, can I wait two weeks or do I fix this myself?
So then I was like, I'm going to fix this myself.
To be fair, I was going to do this yesterday, you know, after the stream.
But I was so tired.
It was like 11 p.m.
And I was on like, to be fair, like when I was in New York City, I was on E.
East Coast time.
So, you know, 11 p.m.
is like 12, 1, 2, 2 a.m.
in New York City.
I was so used to like waking up early and, you know, not going to bed super late in East Coast time.
This is why I don't, I don't know.
This is why I like living in West Coast because like technically it's like a little cheat code where I can technically stay up a little longer because like when your knees kiss it's plus three hours and that like fucks with my brain um but yeah no so um so i like passed out like i literally just i was like i'm gonna i'm gonna lie down in bed for a little bit after the stream yesterday and um i woke up at seven a.m morning but if you think about it seven a morning west coast is uh eight It's like 10 a.m.
in New York City.
So it was an okay time.
So, and then when I wake up, I was like, oh, I should figure this out.
I should really, you know, clean up.
And I looked at the ball, and I was like, oh, my God, it's so gross.
I looked at the ball.
I was like, ah, I even, like, texted, I texted the dog sitter.
I was like, something came up.
Can you look after dad till Sunday?
You know, I didn't give the details on what came up.
You know, I was just like, something came up.
Can you look at, can you hold on to dad for two more days?
So he's not back yet.
Because, you know, I gotta get my life together before he comes back into my life.
I gotta fix myself before I add another person into this family.
Um, but that something is the mold.
Um, so yeah, so basically I, I put on the face mask, um, and try, I just thought I was like, I put on some, like the, the yellow rubber gloves, and then I was just like, okay, I gotta do this outside.
I don't want the spores to like fucking bounce everywhere, even though technically it's been like, it's been populating.
the mold haunts me so I got I have a balcony so I just went outside oh it's just a face mask it's not like a fucking actual like you know ventilation mask I also bought an air purifier because I was like you should get air purifier it's like I should you should get I'm like whoa wait a minute I should get an air purifier I don't know I love this mold I've been dancing around my apartment um so I just ordered an air purifier.
And no, I didn't have one.
I had a humidifier, but I didn't have an air purifier.
So I went outside balcony, and then I just started...
I had, like, three other bowls.
Like, two of the other bowls, one was sort of starting to get moldy.
Because I had, like, two other...
I had, like, two other dishes in my fridge that also didn't finish.
So I didn't finish it.
So then, obviously, mold was starting to grow on that too.
So, you know, those two, they were starting to grow.
Like, it wasn't as bad as the moldy bowl.
It was not as bad as the one that I was like, holy fuck.
Because that entire bowl was just mold.
Because it was just starting to grow.
So I was just getting my spoon.
I got a wooden spoon.
And I just started scraping it, you know, into a little trash bag.
I don't know.
what color it is um i was a little like how does things become black mold no it was just a wooden spoon i threw away the spoon guys i'm it was just like disposable spoons so because it wasn't like green green it was like short of dark
yeah no it was a disposable So, I don't know if it was like black or not.
I think I didn't want to look at it to be fair.
I didn't really like look at it too long.
So, I don't know exactly what color it is.
pretty dark.
So, um, uh, anyway, I, I, you know, I, I first I was, I started padding it.
And then I was just like, oh, it's not coming out.
But like the entire bowl was mostly mold.
So I was just like, oh, I don't really, I don't really want to scrape this.
This is pretty gross.
So I just, after I was like, pat, pat, and it's wasn't coming out i just left it in a trash bag because i didn't want to turn it turn it over again and look at it anymore i didn't want to i didn't want to look at it anymore so i just i was like okay i'll just i'll just leave it there i was like okay i'll just i'll just pay for a new I'll just take them.
I don't know.
It might be like $100.
I don't remember how much.
I don't remember how much the penalty was.
But I was just like I read it at that point.
I was like, you know, I did baby steps.
You know, I scraped the other balls.
There were two other balls that I scraped out that had mold in it.
I did that.
It was just, you know, the other one was like the alpha mold.
Like the first.
that that bull was like the alpha and he won um i just i don't know i wanted to like throw up i wanted to like throw up so i i was just like i'll just i'll just leave it in there and then i put the trash bag in another trash bag because um i got scared because i was like oh what if the spores start clawing out of this other this trash bag so i'll i'll just put it in a dip in a giant trash bag and like double secure it and i left it outside about yeah i double layered it um and then i left it outside the balcony but i also kept my balcony door open because i was like oh i should air it out i was like oh no like with the mode fly back in i don't know i was like i was so scared and confused I was paranoid and everything.
So, and then, and then I, you know, I threw it, I threw it, I threw it out.
I threw it out.
I just wanted to like air, air the place out a little bit and then see if there's any other trash I need to throw out.
Yeah, so, uh, so I was just like, okay.
And anyway, after the stream, I'm going to clean more because, um you know my life's my apartment's a little bit of a mess like I do have cleaners come I do have cleaner come in every once a month but like um I'm a mess there's like boxes everywhere and I still haven't unpacked yet and I may or may not have like you know like when I was like I missed my So when I was packing my suitcase,
I still had like stuff from China in the suitcase.
And all I did was just I, I like, I just put all this like just all the stuff that I did, I wasn't going to bring or like I brought from China from the China trip.
I just threw it on my bed.
And then when I got home, I was so tired.
I just was like, you know how you put your arm and then you drag everything and then it's on the floor.
That's what I, that's like, I'm home.
i'm gonna go to sleep now so it was just like and um it's still on the floor so i gotta fix that i
so um i gotta fix that like today um because i mean i did that yesterday okay i did that too when oh my god give me a sec i just realized i forgot to take um uh i forgot to take my vitamins sake i'll be right back
i'm back i forgot to take my vitamins so i was just like oh shit
how can i be it's because like i was such a sheltered child growing up that never really had a chance to actually take care of myself like by myself so it's like i'm i'm basically a newborn child learning how to be an adult um way too late
so um so yeah so after the stream i'm gonna try and clean up but i also i need a i need to like change my desk mat because it's fucking it's disgusting and i gotta change and i also gotta clean my keep i actually went on amazon and bought um like uh like keyboard cleans because i've been waiting for it i've been waiting for like the second wooden keyboard because they're always like coming out soon it's coming out soon so i was like oh i don't need to clean this keyboard i'll just buy a new one because it's like better it's gonna be better and then it still hasn't came out so i was like i should really clean this keyboard it is pretty it's it's pretty bad i shouldn't i'm i don't think it's coming out anytime soon so i i should really fix this um so like today this is it this week i'm fixing myself guys because see you guys You can fix me.
Guys, see, I am fixable, guys.
I am fixable.
Cycle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's now a good time to ask for a week-length birthday wish for my girl, Failure Bird.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Of course, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
you happy birthday dear little cyclone happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday so i'll do my best today to like um i guess try and fix this also tomorrow i have a sponsor stream it's for pubg blind spot um it's like a top down shoot like a top down okay wait i mean i don't know how to say this job real well naming another game so
oh it's a top down tactical shooter um so it's like you know you could like barricade and stuff like that and like your sea fence yeah so you know what i'm talking about without me naming any other game that might remind you of it
Um, yeah, a top-down tactical shooter, uh, tomorrow.
And I said, um, it was so last minute.
They asked me, like, super last minute.
That's why, like, came out of nowhere.
Um, and I messed up a little bit because I didn't realize it's at 10 in the morning.
So, like, I was, like, looking at the tab.
And, um, um, uh, and, uh, they're like, see you at 10 in the morning.
and I was like
and they're like oh yeah but we gotta start 30 minutes early so it's gonna be 9 30 in the morning I'm like okay I was like okay all right all right I guess I'll see you guys at 9 30 in the morning tomorrow yeah
so yeah I'll see you guys there it'll be on Twitch by the way it'll be I just got, it'll be on Twitch guys, I'll see you guys there at 9.30 in the morning I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm so ready.
So, yeah, I'll be, uh, I'll be playing with Moxie.
Uh, uh, he didn't fucking show up at rehearsal and I was like, we're, you're like, can't make it.
And then I looked at Twitch and he's streaming.
That's just like, I was like, where is Moxie?
And I see him, like, he's streaming.
I was like, I was just like, bro, I had to do, I had to do a 1v2 during, like, rehearsal.
It was, it was crazy.
Yeah.
Um, all right, let's see.
All right, let's, let's play, uh, this is like song.
I don't know how much I'm going to get through for act three, because I know I heard Act 3 is a lot harder, so we'll see how this goes.
I have no idea how it could go for...
Oh, I have to update.
All right, JK, I forgot God.
This isn't like automatically update, so I have to like manually click the update button.
I mean, yeah, Moxie is a gamer.
Like he's been taught 500 in numerous games, so he doesn't need rehearsals.
He doesn't need a note.
What the fuck is going on?
I am booting up the game.
I was like, they're like, oh yeah, Moxie can't make it to rehearsal.
And I was like, oh, that's all right.
That's fine.
If something happens, I literally go on Twitch and he's fucking streaming.
I was like, I can't make it to rehearsal, right?
All right.
That was fucking funny.
Oh Damn, what's my controller?
Okay, there you go
All right, what was I doing?
Oh my gosh, you forgot okay, I also don't remember up play It's been too long Meep, thank you for 10 give the chips.
Thank you.
Yeah, what was I doing?
Oh, yeah, I like destroyed their world hello hello is it okay oh it's just oh wait now uh oh i just got max oh yeah i got max nail upgrades okay i remember now all right so what is my duty now that awaiting the end confront the care take care of his family the ruined chapel beside oh okay well that's easy all right we just gotta
Hello, age other than your children.
I need to go to Bone Bottom.
Go to the chapel.
Broko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yay!
Alright, I have max nail upgrades, so like, it can't be that bad now.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna be like, oh, what happened?
Oh, shit.
Who could have done this?
Oh my god, who could have done this in this poor village?
That's fucked up.
Oh my god.
What kind of fucked up individual caused this to happen?
You must find the one responsible for these evil deeds.
What the fuck?
Ow.
There we go.
Yeah, money.
Yeah.
Don't remember how to play this game.
It's been way too long.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
What's this?
Oh, it's extra lead.
That's cool.
Oh, cool.
It's extra lead.
Alright.
I gotta remember how...
I actually don't remember how to play this game.
It's been way too long.
Is there any extra?
Okay.
Is this a chapel?
This is not the chapa?
Wait, where the fuck is the chapa?
Oh, it's down there!
Okay, it's downstairs.
I thought that was the chapa.
Oh well, free health.
More HP.
Do I need...
Actually...
Am I carrying the right things?
Put it around.
Okay.
I need to make sure I have the right equipment.
equipment long claw uh I don't want the long claw decrease the cost of silk I don't even remember my loadout it's so locked I'm like what the fuck is my load what the fuck was I doing in this game I okay there is the chapel Guys, you don't understand if it's been like more than two days,
like three days, my mind is like, where am I?
Oh, hello.
Cowards, here you hide, even as you cause your own lands to mines.
See, it wasn't my fault.
It was their fault, guys.
It wasn't my fault.
Oh, it's the old man.
It's the racist man.
Our old guy.
You seem to spell the old one.
We only did as you asked, yes?
the snare is sponge the creature consumed you found it to that void don't play daft you should well know our family's fixation surely you had a hunch how else could we hope to trap one of your pale kin or see her consumed with such insatiable efficiency then you have miscalculated gravely the white knight she fell with further the mother Oh,
hell.
The Quake Kings, yes.
We have felt their force even here.
So the mother resisted the dark to save the child.
Wait, they don't, they're not wearing clothes anymore.
They're naked!
Oh my god!
Put some clothes on!
I just realized they're all naked now.
They're naked and free.
Husband?
This is my guess.
I must descend to the void below and see clear that truth for myself.
Oh, and unfortunate.
All of our loom will fall to her flailing.
So it may, but I will not watch Isla while it crumbles.
The groaning docks beyond the caverns of Bone.
There I have seen a vessel able to pass below.
A heavy bell built for descent.
I will only gain access and operator to assist.
I will investigate the docks and uncover the means.
I'm going to be the first in an age to dive so deep old one that space below remains long unseen even to our family for those deaths i'm more prepared than most i will reach the base of this land and know the truth of the new disaster we together have wrote the shell is their cloth the shell hides nothing it's like a hat the shell is just a fucking hat.
Like, I see I could see their fucking belly.
What do you mean?
What the fuck?
That's a hat!
That's not a clothes!
Okay.
Uh, we don't need that.
I feel like.
I can see everything.
What the fuck do you mean?
Let's see, alright, we have...
Find aid in the deep docks to access its diving bell and descend beneath...
Uh, alright, we gotta go to the deep docks now.
Oh wait.
Am I playing it wrong?
How do I play this again?
Is it this?
Oh, there it is, I'm playing it wrong.
It's up.
Yeah, I actually gave the wrong song.
Alright, children, bring me to your mother.
And then maybe I'll give you a tip.
Alright, detox time.
We go this way.
Uh, where do we go?
What the fuck is this?
Okay, right down right.
Okay, right.
Right.
Down.
Is that where I'm going?
Down, right.
Okay.
Oh.
I gotta sit down.
I'm so tired.
Oh, there she is.
Oh, she's okay.
Look, nothing bad happened to her.
Porch daughter.
These black quakes that now rack your hat lands.
I'm seeking to see them quell at the source below.
The lakes of bling.
Which did you send so deep?
Won't you buy?
It is true.
These dogs possess a craft keep of both.
Unless we ourselves cannot help.
Whether filings help or fall, I charge ties us to this board.
But oh, there's the bug to ask.
And if our fate is as dire as your actions suggest, I'm sure he is only needing a gun quite convincing.
Alright, let's get that she's okay.
I need your help.
Sir, I need to head below the lake.
It's a flame.
There is a diving bell at the base of the structure that seems fit for the task.
I require it open and an operator to send it deep.
As one of you upon these docks with mine still sound, that roll must fall to you.
can't you see i'm busy miss ain't got time for not else while the shoveling needs doing no how is he okay out of everybody like all his other brethren got like uh mind controlled choose to aid me or all your efforts will soon be wasted this kingdom crumbles its collapse is inevitable if you wish for your work and your life to continue you must help me now let's shovel Every day I'm shuffling.
So it's got that bad, right?
I guess if that's how it is.
I'll be...
Oh my god, she's fucking screaming.
Meet me below at the diving bell.
We'll see if I can get you ready for the drop.
Oh my god, guys.
I just realized the volume might have been super fucking loud.
Sorry, I didn't know.
I might have Not adjusted the volume Of the game I did not realize how loud the game was Oh it's been fine Okay that's good That's good It's not been too loud Okay so because like it's supposed to be this loud Alright That's good to know Okay it wasn't as bad as I thought it was To be fair not a lot was happening until it started fucking screaming And now I was like,
ooh, that looks really high.
Okay, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Tokyo.
Moss Home Resident here.
I was just minding my own business when these black spirits suddenly killed them.
You know what?
Oh, nope.
Couldn't be me.
I was out on vacation when it happened.
So I don't know.
I was on vacation.
I was in New York City when, you know, when the black...
Dreads started coming.
I don't know.
This was pretty weird.
I was...
I don't know just as much as you.
I know as much as you do about what happened.
And that is like nothing.
I don't know.
Oh.
Oh, I do have enough simple here.
Such a mystery.
I think it wasn't that loud.
Because I was like...
I was like, oh my god.
That's...
um why is it okay down here i don't remember i could just do that oh oopsie that's five we yeah we oops okay left okay left down wee okay let's play all right left oh Can't go this way, but I can go this way.
I'm so paranoid right now.
I guess I don't have the magma charm, so I'm, like, incredibly paranoid.
Okay, I'm going to sit on this sauna real quick.
Let me through, let me through, let me through.
Okay, this is down here.
All right.
Oh, my God.
That was really bad if I fell.
out that's fine that would have been very bad all right here i am knock die where is he where's the guy what the fuck i'm oh there he is hello i'm here oh oh miss how's all this then a lot of dials to be tracking but at least the controls seems in good order from here I can guide your belt down.
Be as best as any bug.
Then you've no power experience with this type of transport?
No one does, Miss.
Them's who used to dive all along dead or curse the half-life.
And there ain't no bug left alive been brave or stupid enough to try.
Till now, at least.
It'll work as best.
I can.
Can't do much more, I'm afraid.
At least the forging of these stocks were built to last.
gotta pray they hold for you.
Here's the key.
They'll see you inside this metal belly.
Pop in there once you're feeling good and ready.
In the meantime, I'll get to see things upset up here.
Oh, that's cool.
Alright.
Time to risk my life.
On the maybe I'll live.
He's never used this machine before, but it can't be that bad, right?
I've lived through worse.
It'll be so sad if, like, this is how she dies.
Nesvier?
Sir, I wish to depart.
Please ready the bell for travel.
Alright, like, she's been through so much, she literally killed a fucking god, and this is how she dies from a goddamn elevator.
It's like when, um, what's his name?
What was that guy that?
Oh, it's like when that mafia boss died because of an SDD.
Um, sure thing, miss.
Sit on the bench and I'll send you down.
Yeah.
Yeah, Al Capone, like Capone.
Yeah, you guys didn't know that?
Oh yeah, and taxes.
He didn't pay his taxes, so that's how the Popo got him.
And then he died because he didn't get his STD treated.
Yeah, he didn't get syphilis treated.
So, like, it ate his brain, and he died.
Is to, or when we treat a spiel.
Oh my god, bitch, I lived.
That's right.
No one can stop me.
Sir, you can hear me.
There has been an accident during this end.
In the end.
In this broken state.
Okay.
Well, I got to sit in this chair, I guess.
Alright.
Bitch, I live.
You can't get me.
Alright, there's no map here.
Oh, is this the void?
Oh, my guys.
These guys.
Oh.
Okay.
So fuck these guys, though.
Oh my god, they're back.
These bugs are back.
The void bugs are back.
The abyss.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
So I do have to...
What do I do here?
What?
Oh, there had to be like some stupid...
But oh my god.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
I ain't getting out of here!
Oh my god.
What the fuck is that?
Okay, I got... I gotta get out of here.
I don't like these guys.
They make me very uncomfortable.
Oh, okay.
No, this guy definitely makes me very... Are you serious?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Alright, well, he seems like a really bad person.
Just a maybe.
Well, he's like half boar.
It's not full boar because he can't, like, fully consume me.
Still not great, though.
Still not great.
Just go down?
A boar light, yeah.
Diet.
bore oh okay now i'm down here i wonder if Shakira can come down here Shakira Shakira I need are you serious okay that's fine oh my god that was not fun the hell what do i are you serious okay um I am confused.
I might be dead.
And I'm also confused.
Okay, we'll just go this way.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we'll just keep...
It's okay.
I feel very safe.
You should...
Use dash to go up this...
Oh, wait.
There's a chair.
Oh, thank God.
There's an actual chair.
Um, I don't know if I want to use this tool.
No, I should, actually.
You know what?
Alright, children, come with me.
Oh, that's where she is.
Is that it?
Is that where...
Um, laces and the silk mother?
Here you lie, monarch, sunk so deep.
Still you cling to life.
Would you let your lands be choked black to protect just her?
Oh, hey, hey there, Lace.
A spider, dear.
What a delight to have you visit.
It is oh, so lonely here at the bottom of the world.
I cannot share your mirth, child.
Your small rebellion above now causes kingdoms collapse.
Letting you live was my rebellion, spider.
I've denied my mother your silk and strength.
mother mommy issues i've won she can thrash and waste and i know her pathetic broken child cause oh my god you can just talk to her communication is key at least your fucking mom is still alive my mom is fucking dead she gave birth to me and then she went to sleep and then she died in her and let it all come down.
Do you feel me?
I will not.
I've already stood the Sentinel for one dying land.
That role I will never play again.
While I live and possess the strength and then my brother killed my mom and possess the strength to resist this kingdom and the bugs within it shall not fall.
It's not a competition.
Spider, spider, what a marvelous specimen you are.
You fight and fight.
He lives as the world crumbles around you.
Barleymen or bugs will soon be crushed to dust, and so you'll be vainly swinging your blade.
There may still be a way to prevent that fate.
I will claim the hidden path, the bloom that repels the dark.
The snails share some fault in the snare.
use of the blade.
They shall help me now.
Seek its counter.
I will return, child.
When I bear the strength to die below and cut this line, finally free from your mother's grasp.
Goodbye, Lace.
Goodbye.
Alright.
I have a new... Escape the abyss.
Alright, cool.
Well, I figure out to get out of here now.
Alright.
Wait a minute okay I was gonna say wait a minute I seem to have lost some of my platforms I thought like my my big bro or just my little bro I don't even know all right my brothers I thought my oh my god you again I thought my brothers oh my god my brother's made it's like told the void that we cool i don't understand erase our fear eliminate our desire suffer no more void cleanse us is this just lord i did all of that for that fucking course it's always lord i don't understand didn't that my bro told told the void that that i'm cool like she's cool she's with me you know
I can't believe my bro didn't vouch for me.
That's fuck.
Oh, wait.
There's a...
There was a...
Oh, I have to go back.
There was a map up top.
Okay, I'll go back.
The self-voy don't know you, bro.
Oh, wait.
There it is.
I don't understand.
I thought we could like that.
Bro, did you not vouch for me?
The fuck, bro?
Okay, nice.
We got the... we got the map.
They got... did you beat that cheese with me?
Little bro self-absorbed.
Bro, that's fucked, man.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
What?
Oh, I have to go right?
Oh, okay.
He he, we're going back.
Alright.
Oh, fuck it.
Let's just go here.
Oh, I have to keep going, right?
That's fine.
Let's have the bench.
Oh, there it is.
I didn't realize that, because it looked like it was just the empty abyss.
Oh, nice.
Okay, that's good that there's platforms.
Uh, Han, they give it a super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I got jolly jolly.
Go ahead jelly bees.
All right beat them up dragons.
You got this Yeah, I got jolly bees in the end so me happy Wait, what?
What the fuck am I supposed to oh it's over here.
I was gonna say How is I gonna reach that?
Okay, we go this way Whoops one of them died for the cause Oh, we go this way way.
Wait, do we go this way?
Yeah, we go this way.
Oh my god, that just scared me.
Wait, I... Do we?
I'm so lost.
It's right here.
Oh my god, I fucked it up.
It's so dark, I can't see fucking anything!
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god, he wants some warm... It's warm.
Oh, we're late.
There we go.
God damn it.
I just can't see shit.
All right, there we go.
I'm here now.
It's like the abyss is like dark or something.
Oh my God.
Who would have thought?
There's darkness in the dark?
That's been crazy.
Far sight.
Um, the far sight can be similar at home.
What the fuck is that?
Over vast distance?
What does that even do?
All right, down I'll go.
As they say, down is up.
It's a progress tracker?
I'm a little worried going down this way.
Damn, not all boys know each other.
Turkey, geez.
Thank you for the super chat, Lolly.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god, that was just bait.
Wait, is it bait?
I don't know.
I've got to try this again.
guys what if it wasn't guys you know what if it wasn't big i got i gotta make sure i gotta i gotta make sure i had to double check i was like oh my god unless you know unless it wasn't daughter of a distant land we who remain have waited long find our strength to yours Kingdom.
What did I get?
I still get new abilities.
Crazy.
I thought I got everything I need.
Silk, sore.
Hold, and then left trigger.
Left trigger.
You would think that one would be up.
Oh, I can fly now.
What happens if...
Oh, shit!
I don't know.
I was like, what happened to the scene?
Do they just, like, give me a time?
You know?
I don't know.
I thought they would, like, wait for me.
You know?
I was like, oh, do you think they'll wait for me?
He didn't wait for me.
Oh, it's not.
I can't believe they didn't wait.
I was curious.
I didn't know if he would wait.
Yeah!
I wouldn't know if it was a cutscene.
Maybe he'd do something silly, you know?
If I like waited, maybe I get an achievement.
Okay.
Well, now that I'm here, I guess I'll leave now.
Oh my god, no, not Diet War.
Goodbye.
Alright.
I can sit down.
Now I can lean.
Alright.
Time to use my newer build.
Watch this.
Oh wait.
Holy shit.
How tall is this building?
Right?
I was like, I did not remember this building being that tall.
Alright, we leave now.
Okay, now I see why it gave me that little shortcut.
It's tall, tall.
Yeah, I was like, Jesus Christ.
I did not remember doing that much shit.
Are you...
Oh my god!
It's fine.
They're like little moles.
See, everything is okay.
Oh, I did not like that that came out of his back.
It was a little unsettling.
Alright.
We're almost out of the abyss.
Too much to do.
Oh, I need to do this.
I'm like a little rock.
I wonder if I can take myself to the moon.
You know, I recently found out that all of this takes place underground.
Like, I just noticed that.
Like, we've been underground this entire time.
Because I'm like, I've thought, I don't know.
Because I thought, like, you know, there are moments where I was...
The moss?
I was like, is that not the Sun?
Like the mossy area?
I recently found that out because it came up in my YouTube shorts.
They're like, oh yeah, because there's like a, like, what was it called?
The Parkour Hell in Hollow Knight.
They have something similar for that in Silk Song.
I forgot what it's called.
The Parkour Hell in Hollow Knight.
Yeah, the Path of Pain.
So apparently there is a path of pain in Silk Sock, which leads to the outside.
And I was like, the outside?
Are we not?
Have we not been inside this entire time?
I was so confused.
I was like, what do you mean the outside?
Because like that moss home looks like the outside.
Because there's like, I was like, is that not the sun?
Like...
Yeah.
is oh my god
this is very scary the fire is making me very are you okay that's fine i think i oh my god it's all the way back here okay i got focus up okay now i got now now it starts now it starts now
Alright, there you go.
There you go.
It starts now.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
The fact that there's no, like, stopping it.
Are you serious?
Oh, God.
I hate this.
Oh, this is so stressful.
This is actually so stressful.
Oh, at least I can get some extra stuff.
Alright.
Where do I go?
Okay.
And then up I go.
Thank god I had the wanderer shit on.
Alright, that's good.
That's good that I have the wandering one on.
That makes like, co-going a lot easier.
I'm oh fuck okay oh oh shit oh I was like I was like hmm I feel like oh goodbye
I was like hmm it sounds like it's getting closer should I be I should be very worried oh my I should be oh shit
I was like, wow, it sounds like it's getting closer.
It only takes one, oh my god, it takes one mistake and then I'm a mess.
Okay, I actually got to focus up for this.
I can't fuck around.
I wonder if that...
Oh, it's all unlocked, thank God.
At least it unlocked that for me.
Alright.
Nice.
Can I remember this?
Okay.
Clearly I didn't.
I thought I remembered this.
Alright.
There you go.
I almost remembered it, okay?
It took one.
It was only one thing.
And now we go here.
And then... I think I...
Oh no.
Okay.
Grab this first.
My full focus on this.
Because this is bullshit.
This one's actually bullshit.
Are you serious?
No, please.
No, please!
Oh, God.
It's getting closer.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Oh, please, please.
Okay.
We're making it.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I thought we made it.
How is I supposed to know
it wasn't over?
Oh, God.
No!
Bro thought we were...
I thought we were done.
I was like, yay!
It wasn't even a checkpoint.
I should have healed I should have healed I was panicking I thought it was over I celebrated Okay Okay I focus for real For real now Okay I was focusing I just stopped focusing because I thought it was over Could you really Is it truly my fault Okay I
Thought it was over so I unlocked in I unlocked myself
Oh my god.
No, no don't do this to me
And we go here
All right, that should be good And then we go up And then we keep going up.
Keep going up!
Keep going up, Doki!
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh god, please, please, please, please.
It's catching up.
It's so fast.
Oh my god.
Fuck, why is it so much faster now?
Oh
my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god, are you serious?
I keep fucking
precise!
Okay, that's good.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
we're so we're so fine guys I don't think we're fine I guys I lied wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait I think we're fine I think we're fine wait no we're fine oh my god oh my god please I told you I told you we are so fine we're so we're so safe we're we fucking did it look at that easiest easiest parkour of my life i told you i told you we were fine now it's just chill time
so easy wasn't even worried at all oh wait there's a chair all right let me just to be sure just to be sure wasn't even worried at all all right nice uh oh i'm back here totally wasn't panicking or anything where do i go now
I'm not even there anymore.
Oh, okay, I did do it.
I was like, what the fuck do you mean?
Return to the snail shamans.
Oh, okay.
What was it?
Call my children.
Pick me up.
Okay, it might not help that I'm on the platform.
Okay, maybe here.
Pick me up.
I'm calling my Uber.
I was like, I don't think they can get here.
Yeah.
Hello, kids.
Wait, can I...
Oh, I can beat up...
Oh, my God.
I can volleyball the...
I'm going to kidnap your kids.
Yoink.
Wait.
Get over here.
Yoink my children now.
If you want to see your kids at back, I want 5,000 rosaries.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we need a, like, a smaller...
Oh, there you go.
You want your child back?
I demand 5,000 rosaries.
How good is you?
This is a kidnapping.
Oh my god, it's like beach volleyball.
Yeah, I'm gonna bring your child to volleyball.
Alright, uh, we gotta go.
Okay, Bonesman, fight him.
Don't see her.
She has like three more kids.
She's not gonna miss one.
If I...
I'm gonna raise it to be my own personal taxi.
So I'll never have to pay again.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, the thieves are here.
I mean, like, they're dead.
So, like, does it really matter to me?
They're just stealing from the dead.
Alright.
Let's go...
Is it here?
Oh, no.
It's all the way to the left.
And now raise your child to be my personal...
My personal Uber.
My personal chauffeur.
I'll never have to pay the fees ever again.
Hello.
Hello, I get the thing.
Let me rest a little bit.
Back from the destiny.
Nearly as scratch is it?
Is that as you fear?
It isn't worse.
Your snare has sunk the monarch deep.
Deeper than I can safely ascend.
To cut fire them free, I must plunge below the surface of that lake of liquid nothing no shell survives submersion in that void old one not even yours not without aid though certain and though aid may exist the flower that resists the dark do you know of it the ever bloom we've heard the tale but i thought it a myth if ever sprout in our lands we should have we should would have surely known that's fine i would not seek it in these lands i need its powers full and it's too fragile to sustain here long i'll seek it in my memory wait i can do that i could just grab something from my fucking memory what if i just grabbed my mom oh so you have rush just open your soul they retrieve the fabled bloom can such a be done like if I could just grab something from my memory I can just grab my mom or my dad or another bug no I but I am a weaver enough to attempt it in the distant past I knew the flower my thread still hold its faint memory if the ever bloom was crashed strongly enough within my
yeah or my brother a big Bro, come over here!
You got the void power?
Yo, talk to the void for me, bro!
It can be made to manifest!
See, I could make it manifest!
Okay, the holiday night is...
Okay, not the holiday night.
Where the fuck he is.
The tiny little guy, the other brother, he's smaller enough to be the size of the flower.
Ah, so you're asking another spell of us yet the night to reveal the fire clear, but to eliminate one of your kind's own memories so acutely.
This is no easy thing even for us.
Oh, no one, you must give us a moment to confer.
They finished talking while I was trying to find my...
cough drops where the fuck did it go oh we could do it the spell can be cast but another when a power enormous power equal maybe to that monarch to me again i cannot grant you mine if it were even were enough my strength is still needed face right below where else do we propose to seek a source from fire loom oh remember ours is a kingdom of wishes granted fire loom was not boring of that monarch old one power existed in these lands even before she bound them beneath her seek the old hearts of our kingdom and the last successor to bear their strength they're still out there in the way much faded by the pale one's long dominion you must make them stir we'll teach you how and the way befitting a weaver a sombre song to reach down in their memories and enliven them a final time All right,
teach me the song.
All right, I learned the song.
The Elegie of the Deep.
Okay, I can draw the memories of Barlooms forgotten past.
The hearts you seek, we can share their locations as best as we know.
They would be needed to construct their spell and draw a clear memory of the flower from your silk.
Bring us the hearts, old one.
Make him be fierce and final.
See for yourself the forgotten strength of this land of bugs before we burn those memories in its saving.
Alright, cool.
Wait.
better leave your land weak in wonder it means your your shell and those are your first all right
i was trying to find um my cough drop i can't find it oh is it here oh wait uh it seems like something i can go up to What's over here?
Oh, what is this?
Secret!
What is this little secret tunnel?
Oh, it's lore.
Eight mask hearts, world soul, and range.
Twelve accounts flat, all justice strained.
Six pilgrims living, hung long to drain.
Is that it?
Oh, no, there's more.
Okay, thank God.
I was going to be like, are you serious?
Is this lore?
Where am I?
Oh, it's like a little shell there.
Like, there's all the snails right here.
Damn.
Mine now.
They're all, like, I guess, like, dead snails?
What did I get?
What is this?
Oh, oh, a new crest!
Cast a blade for it and strengthen silk skills with power change crest.
Oh, it's like a, it's a crest for silk.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Is this the mage build?
Am I a nerd now?
Oh my god, I'm a fucking nerd.
So like, I have like...
Yeah, it's a nerd crest.
I have like, uh, magic now, right?
Like, my, uh, blade does magic?
I want to try it.
Actually, I want to try this.
Is it...
Alright, is this blade actually good or bad?
Is this crest good or bad?
Oh, I can do a big beam if I...
I can calm me, ha me, ha?
Oh, oh.
Oh shit, wait, that's cool.
It's up to the user.
Use it for the true ending.
Is it actually that good?
Oh, oh shit.
Wait, I could do it.
Oh.
Okay, but what the fuck is this, though?
Oh, that's...
Oh, it's a memory locket.
I don't have more...
I don't have any more lockets.
I'm a wizard now.
I'm a what?
I don't know.
which one to use.
I guess like this and this.
Okay, but what are the magic that I can do?
Okay.
Up, down, and that.
Yeah, I have no red slots.
Alright, I gotta test this out.
Alright.
Where can I test this out?
Hello, any children that I can beat up?
Where did they all go?
Oh my god, fucking Pussies.
They're all so Scared of me.
I don't understand.
The best spell for this crest is the one I'm missing.
What am I missing?
What if what did I get here?
Okay, I got there.
Oh my god, I forgot to build these.
The witch one?
a spell in the citadel which one's the easiest boss because they're all pretty fucked up they're all pretty I heard her all pretty hard which one's the easiest I know that I've seen the ant one the ant queen and like apparently she's like one of the hardest right it's the easiest one okay Yeah,
I know it's not the at one.
I heard she's like one of the hardest bosses.
Right is the at one.
Okay, so we gotta go.
Oh my god, where am I?
There's a map.
I'm so lost.
Oh, there it is.
All right.
Top left.
This guy?
The coral tower?
is this not the ant I thought that one was the ant is the ant this one I guess ant should be in the fire fields because that's where all the ant live which makes sense
makes sense I was like I thought this was where the ant lives
chat setting me up okay so I guess I'll go to the middle one then I guess I'll go How do I even reach here?
How do I even reach this area?
Like everything's like locked up
Grand Gate?
What?
Oh here?
From the Grand Gate elevator.
This one?
Is it this?
Or is it this?
Which one?
Is this?
And then you have to go all the way here?
Oh, okay.
Alright, blasted steps.
Alright, take me to blasted steps.
Well, I'm gonna kidnap your children.
I said very calmly.
Alright.
Wait, oh, I don't have my fucking compass.
I just realized, okay, I still want to, I want to try this build out, though.
Oh my god, I can't even try this build out, I just realized.
I want to try it out.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my god, he's so strong.
Oh, that's how I bind too?
That's a weird way of saying please.
Oh, there's pilgrims here now too.
What are they doing here?
Wait.
Oh, they take away my skill!
Oh shit!
I keep forgetting they do two damage.
No!
Where am I?
Okay.
Okay, I forgot to sit on the bench.
Oh, I have to heal on the ground?
I can't even heal in the air?
Okay, I'm getting rid of this crest.
That's the deal breaker.
Wait, am I...
Am I...
Where am I?
Oh, I'm already here.
I...
me on the ground.
That's the deal breaker for me.
Alright.
I gotta fucking get rid of that black mass too.
Where's the... Oh, there it is.
There we go.
I'll get rid of this real quick.
all right all right that's it no more oh wait he's still voided i was gonna say that's right what you gotta do now but he still was able to avoid all right that was this way uh i'm going to carmelida Who the fuck is Carmelita?
Is that the ad?
Are you serious?
I'm-
God, you guys took me to the ad, didn't you?
You guys- You guys are- You guys took me to the ad, didn't you?
It's shut up.
I fucking do it.
I was like, she looks very womanly.
This is not, I swear to God, if I, if I fucking go down to that elevator and I see a John ass ad, I swear to fucking God.
Wait, how do I get down here?
What?
I go up?
Oops.
Oh, go up.
Oh.
All right, have fun, Dragoon.
He can beat up this bat.
Ow.
And him, too, I guess.
Anything here?
No.
So it's only me sure I'm not missing anything.
God damn stupid steam.
If I see a giant-ass ant, I'm turning this- I'm turning this car around.
I swear to God.
It's not here.
Oh,
there's a bench?
Oh.
I guess...
I mean, I have...
It's $15.
It's fine.
I can...
I can be the problem for a part of the problem in super capitalism.
That's alright.
It's a...
Yeah, I can be part of the problem.
Ascend and hold the left wall.
That's the thing I went too far.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
Here, right?
Let's be here.
I will turn this car around if I see the ad.
I swear.
Okay, break vines.
Oh, break vines, right?
Oh, here.
Oh, there you go.
I got the shortcut.
Are any of us here?
Oh, my God, you're back?
Oh, fuck you.
I'm leaving.
I got this.
Secret.
Okay.
Anything else here?
Okay, we go this way.
Oh shit!
You know what?
You go kill him.
I believe in you guys.
Okay, guys.
Okay.
Okay, Jargoon.
Okay, there we go.
I still believe in you guys, unfortunately.
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, that's fine.
It's okay
Okay, I hit my head That's fine That's fine Just a little concussion That didn't hurt nobody It hurt me a little bit But like, you know what I mean Just a little flesh wound
I I can't help it!
It was just there!
Oh my god, I forgot to grab this.
Hey, what's up here?
Oh my god, I almost didn't see him.
I gotta get rid of the void.
I will turn this car around.
If I see the motherfucking at, I will...
Oh hey.
Oh, hey.
Oh.
Hold stranger.
I am charged forever to guard the sacred shrine beyond.
Any who wished the past must cross their weapon with my own.
Oh wait, give me a sec.
I gotta unlock a shortcut.
I'll be back.
Oh, it's him.
It's the make a wish bug.
Seth, right?
I heard about him.
It's actually pretty cool.
Oh, there you go.
What?
Okay, oh, it's this way.
Okay.
All right, so I'm the- apparently Seth has a really cool- cool music or something.
Yeah, he was a- it was a bug designed by one of the- I don't know if it was from Make a Wish, but from a child.
That really loved Hollow Knight.
Alright, let's fight.
I just said, don't worry, I got- I brought a crew.
Oh my god, oh my god, he doesn't care.
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
I-
Okay, um, that was, uh, the awkward.
He has- he's so fast, my brain is- my brain is still waking up, I cannot Comfort ride, Seth.
Okay.
My brain is a bit too slow for him.
Alright, I gotta figure out his patterns.
Does it talk to him again to fight him?
Or does he...
Oh, shit.
No, he does.
He's like, no talk.
No talk, just fight.
Jesus, what?
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
He twers!
Okay.
Oh shit.
Jesus.
Okay.
I need to use my...
Oh my god, fucking teleport's behind you!
I was not expecting that.
Are you serious?
Stupid fucking teleports behind you.
Bullshit.
Okay, I figured it out though.
I figured it out.
Nothing personal.
Okay, I think I know his patterns though.
I figured it out.
I just wasn't expecting him to teleport behind me
I got one knockback though.
It was a stagger though, so
Nice Jesus, okay Not expecting that Okay, I didn't expect that either I just expect nothing.
Okay.
Oh.
There we go.
I figured it out.
Oh, except for that part.
Oh, I figured it out except for that one part.
Where I didn't figure it out And that part too But other than that I figured it out
Yeah Oh my god bullshit
Gotta be more careful no I remember when he does the slam dunk When he does a slam dunk, he dashes forward.
I forgot about that move.
That's so close, though.
The timing.
He's like, friend.
I was like, friend?
But you said, friend.
Okay.
Okay, I just want to grab this first.
Oh, my God, I already forgot.
He used the same move.
already forgot.
Surely, he's like, it's gonna work a second time.
I was like, you're right.
It did.
Oh my god, fuck.
And he was right.
I was like, how did you know?
Okay.
Are you serious teleport behind me?
I hate it when he does that.
I hate it when he does the teleport behind me, bullshit.
Okay.
A dash.
Oh my god, it's so much water now!
Okay, I need you to get...
Ah, you...
It just keeps working.
I don't know how he keeps doing it
Okay, nice.
Are you fucking okay friend my turn to be friend
Nice all right two staggers.
Oh, I did it.
Oh Shit didn't do it.
I didn't do it I was like, yeah!
Guys, I didn't do it, guys.
Oh my god.
I was like, yeah!
Oh, Barry, friendo, friendo!
I didn't learn.
I never learned from my mistakes.
I thought he was like, good job!
I thought he was gonna be like, good job!
You proved yourself!
I think I should get the parry.
I think parry might be good against him.
Just a maybe.
Are you kidding me?
Are you...
Are you seriously double combo me too?
No!
Okay.
I figured it out.
I downloaded you, Seth.
That's right!
Okay, that's right!
I downloaded you!
That's right!
They downloaded you for real!
These other times I'm lying, but this time for real!
Okay, maybe not this time, but this time...
Alright, destroy those slashe.
It's 90, okay.
I'm 99% down.
I'm getting the deflect.
I think the deflect would be better.
I'm 99% down.
This is it.
This time.
I figured it out.
Just because you were a Makoish, doesn't mean...
I'm gonna let you uh let you get away
All right All right, this time for real
This guy Oh my god Oh, that's why Get deflected
That's right get deflected again.
Oh shit, okay He deflected me.
Oh, I was a bit too high there.
I'm going to heal real quick though.
Okay.
That is.
Friendo!
Get dodged!
Oh my god, lucky roll!
I haven't seen that in 20 years.
That's actually the first time I saw it.
Are you fucking kidding?
me yeah I need to focus on heal getting heals now all right nice oh that's fast wait what okay I got this watch this okay now I don't have this there are you fucking kidding me
Are you serious?
Not one time!
So what happened to the 20 other fucking dashes that you were doing?
Okay, there we go.
Okay, now I have to like focus on grabbing up heals.
Oh my god, lucky roll.
Okay.
Get predicted, bitch!
Oh, fuck.
My
friend, though, for you!
I figured you out!
Oh, he's dead.
Oh, whoops.
Oops.
I'm not a bad person.
That's all right.
Look, he started it.
He asked me if he wanted me to...
He wanted a challenge, guys.
I'm gonna hold back.
He asked for a challenge.
I'm not gonna hold back on a challenge.
Where...
I mean, you died.
He started it!
He knew what was going to happen.
It was self-defense.
He already had his wish.
It's called make a wish, not make wishes.
Here we honor the seed that sprung the wood.
By our grace, may all bugs pass.
I told you.
I told all of you.
I said, I swear to God, if it's the end, I swear to God, I turned this car around.
I...
I don't...
It's not the ad.
I swear to God.
If I see a giant ass ad, I swear to God.
If I see that fucking ad, this car is being turned around.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, wait, what is this area?
Oh, it's like the...
She's like a flower.
She's like a flower god.
I'm in a memory now.
Oh, that's a nice memory.
Look at how nice everything is.
It doesn't look too bad.
Hello, girl.
Oh.
Okay.
That's nice to know.
Oh, that's also nice to know that she does that.
Oh, cool.
She can also deflect.
All right, that's okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
I, I.
Are you fucking, are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my God, just fuck me.
I get it.
She's so big!
Like, what do I do?
She takes up the entire screen!
She takes up 50% of the screen.
Okay, but she's not too bad, I think.
Okay, to be fair, I'm only in stage one.
But...
I'm like, yeah, welcome to the Thunderdome.
Alright, I have to use my needle more.
I just didn't think I don't know I I thought she would just stay there like in my head I was like maybe she'll just not move
Jesus are you fucking with that's new oh my god that's new and oh my god she's using all these moves I've never oh my god I've never seen half of these moves before Okay
Jesus I'm like having to think Wait, is she gonna take my platform away?
What the fuck am I gonna do now?
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I was gonna say oh never Okay,
okay, I understand now I understand.
Things got a lot more clear now.
I was like, oh, that's easy.
That's easy.
I just gotta go back and forth.
That's all.
What happened to my floor?
Wait a minute.
Where did my floor go?
Can I just like kill her in her sleeve?
Like, good.
Apparently it's easier to just pogo hair.
Is it?
Oh my god, it is.
I can't...
Oh, guys, never mind.
Guys, never mind.
Now I know.
It's not easier to pogo hair.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Wee!
Toho!
oh my god please don't get rid of my floor oh god oh god i said don't get rid of my floor
oh my god oh god oh god it's okay it's my little oh my god never mind it's not okay it's no longer okay i no longer feel okay i no longer feel okay
oh my How do I poke on that?
Oh shit!
Juicy Hills come over.
Okay.
I'll just wait for her to come over.
I don't want to deal with this.
I can wait.
I can't wait.
I can't...
Never mind.
I can't wait.
Never...
Never mind.
You don't.
But, um, I'm just gonna pass out a little bit.
The green, the green, she waits for no one.
I can't even poke, I have to say, like, uh, I thought I could pogo, like, the vines below, but silly me.
Silly me.
Jesus, I need to remember when she does that, I can do this.
Okay, nice.
We use this against her and then Toho.
Okay, never mind, no Toho.
Like I didn't want Toho anyway.
Toho is for losers.
Oh my god.
I just get hit by everything.
It's okay.
Right.
Bye, floor.
It was nice knowing you.
It was a pretty cool floor.
Nice.
Are you serious?
You know, I'll wait here.
Oh, no!
Ah!
She was just standing there menacingly!
I don't understand.
She's a flower.
She's a fucking flower.
How much damage can a flower do?
Like, oh, I'm sorry, I broke five ribs.
I got hit by a flower.
I...
Sorry, I can't come to work right now.
Broke my fucking legs.
Oh, damn it.
It's not even poised.
She's not even poisonous.
Yeah.
Jeez, thank God I got the luckiest.
Oh.
Okay, I'll just use that.
I guess I don't just use that.
Oh, God.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Goodbye, platform.
We're pretty cool.
Oh, God.
Nice.
Oh, I'll wait here a little bit.
I can chill here a little.
Oh, yep.
Oh, Bob.
so fine.
Oh, it's so fine.
Oh, okay.
I need her to go down so I can have like a little bit of room here.
Whoops.
Just get hit by everything.
I was doing so well.
And I was just like, you know what?
I feel like getting hit by every single thing this bitch is gonna offer me.
Oh, God.
It's too late.
for me they were so prepared
so thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
i'm such a yeah tactical getting hit by everything yeah
My strategies.
You can't comprehend my strategies.
Alright.
Okay.
I could parry that.
Actually, I should do that.
Are you serious?
That doesn't count.
I was just out of range.
Oh my god, I timed that.
How is that possible?
I timed that.
It's not perfect me!
That's crazy.
Oh, that's- that's cool.
That's also cool.
That's- you know what?
That's fine.
Are you serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I didn't even do anything!
They come over here.
Oh my god.
I don't know where else to go.
I don't know.
I could have actually just buried it.
Okay, I'm locking in.
I'm locking in this time.
Okay, I'm locked in for real.
I know what to do.
Watch this.
to do.
It's time.
Oh, someone give him a gun.
This is it.
I've unlocked my hidden potential.
Okay, but like starting now.
My hidden potential is starting.
Are you serious?
Jesus Christ Where did that guy come?
Okay, that's all right.
I didn't need him.
I don't...
Okay, this is not good.
This might not be good, guys.
Guys, it's a slow burn.
Okay, it's a slow burn.
It's a...
Oh, we're back.
Oh, guys, don't worry.
I didn't die or anything.
I waited for you guys.
I knew my I knew the stream was down So I waited for you guys.
I didn't start the fight yet chat.
I was just I was just making sure you guys could watch me beat the boss so I I like waited for you guys outside the dream I'm so considerate.
I am
Okay, I don't want to use too much of I don't want to use too much of my parry Because I want to make sure I can heal
Alright, this is fine
Alright, there we go Okay, I timed it I told you I can time it perfectly It just took like seven tries But I told you Eventually it'd be perfect Okay Okay, but not now.
Oh
my, that was...
That was so greedy of me.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, I don't think that hits me.
I will stay here then for now.
Because I want to heal.
But I don't have enough silk yet.
Come on, get over here.
Okay, I can heal.
Oh!
All right, you know you want to come over.
Look how empty this place is.
Wait, ah, shit!
She knew.
I don't think this hits me, right?
No, I'm fine.
I'm out, you know you want to come over.
Ha ha, look, it's free real estate.
Oh, man, look how free this area is.
Head over, girl.
You up?
you up girl there you are you fucking how did I get hit those goddamn spikes there you go easy I told you see I told you I died on purpose because I knew the stream was down so then after you guys came back I locked in we are life We are growth.
What world without us?
First try.
I told you.
It was a slow burn.
It was step one of a 10 step program.
We did it.
Yay!
Got the pollen heart.
It beats faint and fast.
First try.
Alright.
Now.
That's done, right?
So I can call up.
I can call my children.
Alright, we'll do Coral Tower.
We'll save the Atlady last.
I don't think I'm strong enough yet.
Alright, how do we get to the Atlady?
Not Atlady, the Coral Tower place.
Oh, wait, we did this already.
Oh, it's literally the same thing.
We already did this.
There's a chair here.
I forgot we unlocked that area.
It should be fine.
Unlocked it already.
I don't remember if I had to do all the parkour again.
Because I did unlock it.
But I don't remember if I unlocked it fully.
Oh my god.
Do I need to flex for him?
Wait, I need a thing.
Oh shit.
Oops.
Guys, I should stop thinking.
Because my mom's not parkouring.
It doesn't work too well.
Parkorn.
You don't think when you're parkorn, you feel.
You gotta feel the parkour.
Feel the jumps in your soul.
This way.
Alright, up back.
Yeah, unlock.
Oh, no, I didn't.
unlock it oh my god are you fucking there's no way no it can't be that okay it's just jumping that's good okay i was gonna say i swear to god if i have to do more parkour i swear to god if i have to do that bullshit thing we're at the uh hit the red thing and then jump around i oh that's gross all right time to play my song
I don't need to go on a bench.
I just spawned outside his body anyway.
Why would I need to go on the bench?
I'm literally in his dreams.
When I wake up, I don't die in real life.
Oh, oops.
I guess I'll go to the bench.
Never mind.
I guess I go to the bench.
Alright.
Okay, now for real.
Can't believe I went out of bounds.
and it forced me to wake up.
Yeah, I just left.
You know how you're like, you could take this mission, or you can just...
Oh, it's like that Pokemon game where like, you can just leave the city, apparently.
I just left.
I was like, I don't want to be a hero.
Oh, that's beautiful.
It used to be a beautiful place.
What the fuck happened?
What did they do?
Wait, you used to be pretty what the fuck do they do to it they like pollute the shit or something this used to be so pretty all right dragons do your thing you got this dragons do your thing oh shit what did they reflect okay I think I might have to change the magic oh no not these guys oh no oh wait it's not I thought it was the other ones I thought it was the one where they sent a stupid fucking ricochet thing I'm not scared of these guys.
What the fuck are these though?
Oh, they're like freebies.
Okay, I'll heal now for now.
Oh, I definitely want to change my...
I think it's too late to change it.
I definitely don't...
Oh, I don't like the magic for this.
I'm tanking it, I'm tanking all of it.
Nice.
Oh.
Yeah, we did it.
Ow.
And that gets a critical hit?
I like how, like, random enemy number one, the random mob gets the critical hit.
I like the deflector.
minions.
Are you serious?
Okay.
Oh my god, I missed.
I fucking missed.
It's fine.
It'll work.
No!
I didn't take you to double it.
I didn't.
I was like, it's fine.
I can just this.
I thought I thought I knew.
Okay, I also need to get rid of the map, the deflect.
I think deflect is fine against bosses, but when I'm fighting against the little guys, it's just very annoying.
I, in fact, cannot tank it.
Who would have thought?
It's crazy.
Uh,
when this place became did they do fracking like is that it
there are too many cars okay okay too many cars and factories so it over polluted
too real
oh my god did not mean to heal oopsie
Alright.
I mean, these guys are easy.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Oh shit.
I guess not for him though.
You know what?
I'll heal.
How did I get hit by that?
I was using a magic spell!
Okay, thank God my needle is maxed still.
I don't know how I'm gonna fuck me.
How would I have survived if my needles weren't maxed out?
There we go.
One!
All right, give me the silk.
Yay!
All right.
These guys are not that hard.
Okay.
Yeah.
I see it.
What?
You can interrupt that?!
That's bullshit!
Alright, nice.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's just for silk.
Okay.
It's just a silk bar.
I mean, that's nice.
I'll just leave that here.
Oh, no, it's these guys.
Oh, these guys I hate.
They're the ricochet.
Can I destroy this?
No, I can't.
No, wait, wait, no, not my stealth!
Don't destroy the stealth dragon!
Stealth!
You killed everything!
Fuck the minions!
Okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
It's over!
It's so...
Over
Okay, wait wait second life second life
You serious Oh my god, please Just let me all let me hit you at least once I hate this
This, I...
Oh, God.
He was right there.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh, no.
I don't feel so good.
I don't...
Okay, these guys actually...
Are you...
Oh.
I'm like, get it!
No!
It's just...
I don't know what to do.
They just...
They just start running, and I'm like, I must follow.
What if I just touch it?
The big boys, I just want to touch it.
I swear, I swear to God.
I feel like the arena's the hard part and then the boss itself would be like a lot easier.
I couldn't help it.
His ass was like the moon.
And then I just wanted to follow it.
I was a lamp drawn by the ass.
Why the fuck did he come here?
Brog!
Alright.
You know what?
I'm just gonna get rid- Are you serious?
Just gonna heal real quick.
Oh my god!
Okay, I guess not!
No healing for me!
Alright.
I'll heal here.
Alright, her sister here is back to avenge her sister.
All right.
It's okay.
You can face take in the first round.
I've learned.
I mean, I don't have to, but I'm lazy.
When the...
When the moon hits the eye...
It's Amori.
himself.
Yeah, I got the crit on the silk guy.
I don't get the crit when it matters.
Are you fucking...
Oh my god, tip over here!
I swear to god.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I know, like, these don't take a lot of his.
Thank god, too.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Okay, I'll use the silk and then...
He can fight back!
I thought you were just here for the silk!
I didn't realize you could actually fight back!
Since when?
Okay.
I'm just gonna grab this for now.
I just need to know that...
When he does that, he summons a little Koro shit.
Oh, there he goes.
Summoning the Koro shit.
Alright, friend time.
There we go.
Maybe a Dracus.
Oh, nope.
Dracus, no!
No, that's my silk!
A one time.
He'll
hit.
Friend.
Alright.
Oh, and he's dead.
You know, he tried.
Don't jump, please.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Alright, we did it.
Oh, we did it.
I just had enough magic to use it.
Our silk now.
Is there a shortcut?
Oh, please tell me there's a shortcut.
There's...
Okay, there's still...
Oh my god, you fucker.
Where's the shortcut?
Shortcut?
Guys, this is silly.
Shirley, the shirt coat is somewhere...
Not yet.
It was you guys.
Shirley, the shirt coat is like right beside me, right?
Oh my god, they decided not to come closer.
They fucking...
Are you serious?
Oh my god, they're actually locking me in.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
That's good.
Maybe they'll get closer, right?
Please, if you want to engage in this fight, you have to get closer to me.
I know.
I know it's a crazy concept.
All right.
This guy, I hate this guy.
I hate him.
I'm fucking gonna slam dunk him.
Jesus Christ.
Friend.
Where am I?
Okay.
This is fine.
I don't want to waste any of my silk magic on him.
Okay, he'll slam dunk.
I'm just gonna waste it.
Wait, what is he?
What the fuck?
What is this?
What is this guy do?
He's just bubbling.
Okay.
Grab this for the free still.
He's like a bubbly man.
Oh, not him again.
Oh, God, not him again.
Okay, there's more.
Oh, shit!
There's...
Oh, fuck!
Of course I'll waste it!
I'm just going to use some magic for now.
Because I don't trust myself!
See, this is why I don't trust myself.
There you go.
Oh?
Oh.
That's not cool.
Um...
Oh Really oh
You just float right here.
Oh, okay.
Don't worry.
He'll yeah, he cleared it.
Ah
Look he he did clear it.
I just wasn't
Okay He technically did clear it.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay, I don't know- oh shit!
I'm like really scared about this guy.
So I'm gonna use all my silk for that.
Like I don't know what the bubble mana actually can do.
He's fucking kidding me?
Are you- Ah!
Ah shit!
Oh, God.
Okay, slow and steady.
Throw your little thingy.
Okay, I'll just...
It was a bit too slow.
What?
Okay.
Oh, my God!
Okay,
nice.
Oh, thank God.
Thank you for the free stuff.
Thank you.
You're so kind.
Thank you so much for this freestyle.
Come, yum, yum, yum.
Alright.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
We're at the boss.
Was that the shortcut?
Oh, we got the shortcut.
Yay!
This has to do with the boss now.
Thank you for the crumbs.
You were so nice to me.
I'll just blow you up.
Wait, this isn't a boss, but...
This is just a minions.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Oh, okay, goodbye.
Goodbye, free soot.
I never need it.
I hate this.
Are you kidding me?
Ah!
Okay, that's fine.
That's not fine.
God stop the not the geometry not geometry it's always geometry oh my god she jumps back I'm so confused there's so many things to dodge
All right, there we go.
Oh.
Oh, we made it.
Yay!
Okay.
This is the king now.
Hello, king.
Am I worthy?
Am I worthy now?
Okay.
I have no idea what your pattern is.
Crust King.
I thought I said like Genghis King.
I was like, oh my god.
Bug Kang?
Oh shit.
Grand.
Alright.
I was like, oh my god.
There's a Genghis Kang a fucking...
Buzz?
Oh, I didn't expect that.
Oh He lands Gotta be like super careful because oh my god I did it again I was like don't worry.
I'll be super careful this time Friend I
mean like he's pretty predictable so far
Like, he just uses the power of spikes.
Oh, he ain't, like, actually gaming.
Like, I literally just...
I just hit him.
He does more damage by just existing.
Other than anything else.
Literally, only damage he does is just he stands on me.
I don't keep this I can't help it
I mean it goes I guess it's a little faster
okay where's the land where's this bullshit
okay just make sure I don't land on him are you fucking kidding me how the fuck do I have What's that?
Okay, this is actually bullshit.
Like, I can't even get close to you!
He just blocks everything!
He's like, no touchy.
I literally, no touchy.
Oh my god.
Are you- I-
he's got the defense he actually has the defense that's so bullshit they are so bullshit i literally i just i just sat there i i thought that's all i could do i could only just sit there as he was playing he just played defense
he is easy play like a hundred percent defense zero attack also didn't help that kept fucking just running into him it it was definitely a little stupid i just kept running into this guy he finally locked in he really did is it this way which way it was this way right literally He died by getting sad.
Oh.
Oh, it is.
Okay.
I'll just do this then.
So, thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm skipping all the silk, though.
It's fine.
Do I have to...
Oh, I have to fight these guys again.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't realize I had to do the arena again.
Yeah, it's fine.
Okay.
I could do about the deflect.
You should be fine.
Oh, wait.
No, it's not fine.
Wait a minute.
It might not be fine.
Because then I lose Bubbly Mad.
It's just more tedious fighting.
Bubbly Mad.
Are you serious?
Oh, God.
Damn geometry!
My one weakness!
Okay.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Alright, nice.
I didn't have to do that, I just wanted to flex a little.
Alright.
Now I should be able to go back up.
Rocket time.
Okay, maybe deflect would be a little easier.
Also, I got you guys here along for this fight.
I swear, I felt like I was fucking...
I stabbed him so many times.
I felt like I was stabbing him so many times.
Wait.
Oh.
I was trying to do that Look, there was a plan I just might have fucked up my original plan
What?
That doesn't work?
Are you serious?
It keeps happening
Okay Okay
It's fine.
I don't know when I can use my dip deck, but it's fine.
It's so fine There you go
Are you serious?
You just now?
Are you spread here?
I'm gonna get you.
That's right.
Holy shit.
This was so much faster.
What the fuck happened in the first fight?
I swear it took like 80.
Like, he just stopped doing defense.
He's like, you know what?
Maybe I could try 99% defense.
Our claws to crush.
Our claws to rule.
Our claws to save them all.
Like, now, I was like, now it's like 99% defense.
I swear, the first fight was 100% defense.
He would not even let me get close.
Maybe I am.
I got sad on Go to Graymore Why It beats deep and slow One rings and roll them up
Alright Nice Alright it's time to play my song Do do do do do do do do
do Alright we'll do the We'll fight the ant first Before we go to Graymore Alright how do we get Okay it's far fields right I heard I have to use the deflect for her Okay Firefields Alright how do we get to
Oh you get there from Hunter's March?
Oh it's Hunter's March Oh okay Fuck how do I get to Hunter's March It's been so long Um Okay, I have to go...
Jesus Christ, okay.
Let...
Oh my god.
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me figure this out.
It's been so long.
Okay, deep docks.
Okay, it's faster if I was in deep docks.
It's actually faster in jump deep docks.
Beast of Bellheart?
And then down?
Why?
Oh, where's Bellheart?
Oh, yeah, I see why.
Ah, now we're at deep docks anyway.
This works.
Deep docks is...
Oh, I have to enter from the Morrow?
Where the fuck is that?
Where the fuck is the Morrow?
Oh, other way is blocked?
Oh, that's the Morrow.
Oh, so I have to go from bell heart okay go from bell heart it's been so long since we've been there
i forgot it exists you don't understand like we have not been here and so why are they all so depressed it's like it's like their entire town is that like it's like their entire town is lost or some shit
how do i go downstairs Oh, there it is.
Wait, no, that's not it.
Well, now I'm upstairs.
It's like the world is ending for them.
I don't understand.
How do we go downstairs?
Just don't be sad.
Oh, the bell station?
There's a wish?
What's the wish?
Oh!
Come to my home, accept my child.
Sure.
That's fine.
I'll...
Born the hugs, corrupting everything.
Oh, sure.
Oh, it gives me a mask.
Bro, just go outside.
Yeah.
All right.
It's from the bell station?
Oh, here.
I remember now.
Should go down for...
okay we still go down from there like despite what happened we still we still need to go down from oh no wait like that does nothing he can't even do anything he just flies oh my god he can't even do what would the void do with this man he just floats
all right go this way okay hunter's march tag
Okay, right...
Right up, right...
Cock-court!
Okay.
God, the Wonderer crest is actually saving my ass right now.
Oh, there's the...
That black... Ooh.
I can't... I can't...
Don't!
No!
Oh, God.
Oh!
I can't forget.
I forget the void shit does 2x damage.
The goddamn fucking trap.
God damn.
God damn stupid ass traps.
Why do you get...
Because I forgot they do that too damage!
Like
the fucking void give them stair words or some shit.
How Fuck was I was supposed to remember that they're they're filled with steroids They're drugged up
Avoid enhancing drugs
Oh my god.
Oh my fucking course you were there Fucking course They're juiced up Oh, I forgot the bench.
It's okay.
Surely I'll be fine right
and then doki never learns your lesson wait i can find this guy
your purpose is to provide me silk
okay that should be enough to heal me right yeah i just want me full hp before i go back into this
where's my
It's fine.
Oh my god, never mind.
This little guy also decides to fuck me up.
My toes.
Oh.
That's not okay.
Okay, we got one of them.
Oh my god, no, they got voided.
Oh my god, okay.
That's okay.
Alright, Dragon, I'm bringing you into this fight.
You're coming into this fight, whether you like it or not.
Yeah, I'm going to hell with me.
Are you serious?
Oh, you guys.
Friend.
I got lucky dice, bro.
Put me in, coach.
If I have to go to hell, I'm dragging you down with me.
I don't need to fight them.
Okay, and then we go...
Up.
God, roll.
Thank God.
We technically go to the bench right now.
Let's just go to the bench first.
I know deflect is very important.
for this fight.
All right, it's time.
Oh, there she is.
There's the ant.
Uh...
Okay, it's not working.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh.
Oh, it's up.
I thought this was her.
Alright, we're supposed to go up.
I was like, why is this she waking up?
Hello?
I played you a song.
Please wake up.
Oh, hey, that's nice.
The boy didn't get him.
Oh, that's annoying.
I mean, I guess you want to come along with me?
Shit, okay, I'm gonna wait here.
Don't worry, come over here.
You're not coming on this trip.
There we go.
What?
What the fuck?
Are you serious?
Oh!
There we go, I was like gonna- what the fuck is going on?
All right, knock knock.
Oh, I guess no knock knock.
Oh, far fields.
I'm supposed to go down.
Oh my god, wait, there's a mama!
How am I supposed to go?
Guess up here?
Oh my god, I'm so good.
confused.
It's like you're so... Oh, wait.
Nice.
Free items.
Alright, yoink.
Let's take your shit.
Free loot.
He's been guarding his...
He's been guarding his 401k for 20 years.
Poor thing.
That was his retirement fund.
Yoink.
My retirement fund now.
What is this?
Oh, it's just shells.
Oh, shit.
It's the one jump that matters.
Down, I'll go.
Yeah, he's dead so he can't retire now.
It's a shame that there was an accident.
Such a shame.
Oh my god.
There's so many levers.
I knew it.
I knew this was a secret.
A secret tunnel.
Oh.
Oh, what?
Get out of here.
I know you're hiding.
Oh, what a shock.
Discover it again so easily.
Like a helpless little hatchling.
If you're gonna make a sport of tracking me, I'll have to redouble my efforts at camouflage.
all right good yeah oh there she goes screaming again oh no i was like bro where are you doing here how did she even get here can't even fly
what what's that for
all right yeah how did she get here i have to fucking go through her head get this ability to do all that shit.
Where does this go?
She and I are not the same.
Oh my god, this is so bad.
This is actually so bad.
Oh no.
Are you serious?
Okay, that's...
He does it!
Oh, goodbye!
Oh my god, to do all of that again!
I didn't think that void will be there!
Oh my god, so far.
It's so far.
That's the worst fight.
It's so fucking far.
There's a shortcut!
Like...
A fucking curse.
There's a shortcut that I didn't happen to get.
There's always a shortcut.
There's always a goddamn shortcut.
Oh my god, I was so close.
I'm not dealing with a mama.
I'm leaving.
You can have this place.
As soon as shortcut opens that, but like how the fuck do I open that?
Okay, let's grab our shit first.
How do I get there?
Is this way?
Um...
And that's, oh, fuck, I forgot how long I have to cross from here.
Yeah, I'm not touching the ground.
I'm too scared.
Okay, so there's a bench here.
Where does this, where is this taking me?
Where, where is this taking me?
What?
Oh, there is a bench here.
Who is this?
Who is this guy?
Hello?
Ho ho!
A nimble opponent appears at last at last.
Maybe you're seeking challenges, sir.
You choose a location less far field.
Is there a rare chance I or any bug would come upon this distant cavern?
True.
Though, once discovered, could there be a perfect spot that giant bony body so distant from far looms else?
Hello?
Here, fear severely.
We can test our speed.
in our sleek shells.
Here we may race.
You may be eager to step on the task, Challenger.
Fulfill my wish.
Let's discover it.
No.
I need to get my shit first before I fight you.
Remember Sprint Master?
I do not remember.
You're asking the wrong person.
I absolutely do not remember.
Whatever the fuck that is.
All right, I'll fight him later.
I need to grab my shit first guys I'm not fighting him with half my silk
Where is it it's like right here or something there you go.
I'll come back then all right Time to do some cardio
It's a race.
Oh my god.
No, not the fuck I ride just fucking slap him just fight you.
You not see my legs?
Dita's legs are enough for running.
I could barely support my fucking head with these legs.
Alright, how does this go?
Magnificent!
May a mighty contest of shells commence!
But final no, Nimbabug.
Have you ever run off course or desire a quick convene?
Simply play.
what music you're able and my companion shall whisk you back to our starting line now the track calls us allow me a moment to assemble a course worthy to test our skills
oh my god
what the fuck
Okay, this is not fair.
This is not fair.
It's like he knows this course or some shit.
Like, he built it.
Like, oh my god, it's...
It's not fair.
It's like he built this course so he knows how to run this race.
Okay.
Bro, Bro can literally fly exactly!
Oh my god, I need to remember not to jump for that.
Go, go, go, go, keep, go.
Oh my god, it's so close.
It's actually so close.
Oh, we did it!
We got the first race!
Oh, I can hit him?
Oh, I can.
Oh, that's good to know.
Oh, is this a V?
Can it be?
I shale so fast.
Wonder if I loom.
A bug whose pace can match my own.
Though I said simple course, we have proven it's matching more.
Take this small reward, nimble bug, and remember well, I grant.
That's just money.
I thought...
I thought I'd get a mess.
Wait, how many races does he make me do?
do two
more okay two more well now that i know that i can slow him down makes it a lot easier that's freaking right
okay oh my god i don't know where to go it's up
We restart.
We restart the race.
I am fucked up.
I didn't realize it does that.
Okay, this time.
This time.
I figured it out.
Okay, I like that I can beat him up.
That makes it a lot easier.
Yeah, that makes it a lot easier.
I ran out
of...
No!
I ran out of silk!
Okay, that's fine.
It's sound...
It's fixable.
It's fixable, guys.
Oh my god, maybe it's not.
Guys, this might not be fixable, guys.
I don't know.
Oh my god, he's so fucking fast.
He's so...
Guys, this might not be fixable, guys!
Guys, it's not fixable!
It's so over.
It's...
Oh my god.
The things I do for a mass.
Guys, it was not fixable.
It was not I
need to just use my harpoon I know Okay
Okay Oh god
There you go
Okay, okay.
It's fine.
No!
I feel like I need more silk for this.
I'm fucking getting more silk.
I'm getting more silk.
It's not worth it.
Oh my god, it's so far too.
I can't even, oh my god, it's so far.
Also, I just realized, um, I just realized I forgot to like turn on the jumping thing but i'm too lazy to turn it on right now oh
my god what the fuck i wasn't running
okay i need to make sure not to double jump i had to double jump that though like like there was no other way i wouldn't have made it i didn't have that momentum
I missed the jump.
Oh, like, I don't know if I can make it to that third race.
I was doing so well, too.
Apparently, charms don't work in the races.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
okay because I would use the I would use the charm if I could all right Jesus Christ he's so close he's like literally right on my right but he's right beside me isn't he he's right behind me isn't he
oh my god he's right there oh my god oh my god i accidentally
oh my god please please please yes i did it all right we got a third race race down by three truly incredible was it a course did i lose focus or you suddenly the bug i waited so long for Her is such skill that my wish could.
Alas, be granted.
Another reward must be given for your speed.
Nemo bug.
One deserved and full.
What if I just fucking get a crowbar and hit it and just whack his knees?
It shall be improved.
Yes, yes.
The truest test is to come.
We shall fly fast together once more.
Our last race was grand, yes?
But I see now I said to a mile.
A chance for one as friendly as yours.
I prepared only to race.
but your eye bring destiny and you my wishmen finally be granted the barriers of speed broke and wide are you prepared nimble bug the time is upon us the final test for the swift and spray okay sad this is not fair he built the course himself so he knows all the shortcuts
yeah i got it
like i don't He's just flying over the course!
Like, what the fuck do I do?
He's cheating!
He's literally cheating!
No!
I ran out of self Oh my god I had I just had to whack him I just had to How am I cheating?
Oh Just because I accidentally hit him with my stick Did you not see that relay voice Where that girl was doing the relay Accidentally hit that girl in the back of the head With her baton It's just like that It's all just an accident
Like, how is that my...
Oh, my God.
Accident.
Oh, hello, Tata.
Ah, stop here.
There you go.
We do it again.
She said it was an accident.
If she could say it's an accident.
Oh, sorry.
Accidentally hit him.
I'm so I'm so silly
Like I keep I just ran out of silk.
I literally I just ran out of silk.
I literally can't do it
Okay, I just can't grapple twice Oh, I can pogo him It's too much, it's just too much boo-going.
Get out of here.
Yeah.
Oh my god, okay.
I'll figure it out.
No!
Okay.
Okay, okay.
This time.
I figured it out this time.
It's just a lack of silk.
That's really it.
I think if I...
If I had a full silk, it definitely would be a lot easier.
Okay.
No, I can pogo.
I can pogo.
I just, I'm trying to do like, I'm trying to skip it with my needle.
It was so sad.
Why can't he give me a full set of silk?
Why does it just give me this tiny ass little nub?
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's not a part!
It's just that fight!
I keep fucking that fight up!
I don't know why!
All right.
I almost got it.
I could feel it.
This is it.
This is my character arc right here.
I've downloaded it.
Here we go.
Watch this.
Okay, this part is...
I'm just so slow in this area.
I don't know what to do.
To be faster.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Oh.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright, alright.
Accidentally jumped there, but that's okay.
It's salvageable.
Oh my god.
Oh!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I know I'm faster!
Yes!
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
Oh, that was close.
That was so close.
Oh, he done it.
Oh, hoof.
Never will I believe the shell so fast in all of our loom.
Wonders of wonders.
I saved it.
Capricorn, Nimblebug, fulfilled my race.
Wish, seeing my pace match, I mean, my limits broken wide.
Yay!
Wish granted.
I got the mask.
Wait, before you depart, your exceptional skills required.
equally fine reward.
The shodding is sorry of ancient masochists yours.
Take it and cherish it and know you shall forever have my thanks.
Yay!
I just need one more mask and I get another HP.
Goodbye.
I hope we never meet again.
I hope you break your legs.
Okay, but what does that last race get me?
Like, is it just exposure?
Like, I leave.
Yeah, but does it actually get me anything?
Oh, a momentum?
Fuck that shit.
I don't need him from... I don't even remember anything from him.
A fun medal.
It's fine.
I don't need to remember him.
In fact, I hope I never see him again.
Is it worth killing, is this?
I'm just like thinking.
Are you serious?
Please.
Oh my god.
At least I killed him.
He can't hurt me no more.
It's fine.
I'll kill the source.
It's okay.
I killed the source.
Alright.
He can't have no special powers anymore.
Okay.
Now.
Alright.
Parkour.
See, the source is gone.
Can't be special no more.
That's fucking right.
You're not special anymore.
No more void for you.
What?
Excuse me.
How did that happen?
But I'll kill the source.
Wait a minute.
make any sense about that.
But I've killed the source.
Oh, they can randomly become possessed?
What the fuck?
And what's the point?
Is this a shortcut?
Okay, now I got the shortcut.
Wait, did it open?
Okay, it did.
He had leftovers.
Soon, this is where she lives.
Okay, but what's up top then?
Oh.
Oh, for a bench.
Oh, okay.
I was gonna save.
What lies on the top?
I have to deflect on, right?
Yeah, I do.
Memory lock it to the right?
Or like this right?
Oh, there it is.
Him?
Oh my god!
Oh, it's my god!
I did not expect that.
I did not expect that either.
Fine, I got bread.
Jesus Christ.
He did so much fucking damage.
Alright, memory lock it.
But I'm fast as fuck, boy.
Everything over here?
No.
It's just normal.
Oh, there might be something up here.
I knew it.
I knew he was gonna fucking block me there.
Okay, never mind, there is nothing.
He was like, yeah, there is something here, it's me.
Pain is... Oh, there she is.
Why are you so sad?
It's because you're not beautiful anymore and you're old.
For the mother.
Remember my children.
Wow!
Toki!
Oh, just because you're old?
Don't worry.
Someone out there would like hugs.
Yeah, my name.
Hell, be spring, ruined by a censer.
You're writing harsh, your final fate.
Empower, you come seeking.
Mine is faded.
Great one.
I come not to see you as you are.
rather i will have you recall what you were before the pal monarch when once your heart beat bright and brave the beating heart i would take they'll know my intent is worthy i seek it only to save these lands to break them free from his fatal sickness born a threatened void you may beast if you can mine wants power wild and pride all right time to play don't worry someone will attack that.
There's a lot of fishes in the sea that would tap a hag.
Yeah, I heard she's like super hard.
That's why I left her her fucking last.
Alright, here we go.
I've also like seen a bit of like the fight for her.
She looks very tilting.
She looks very, very hard oh there she is look see oh my god how did you grow so big you could tap that now if you weren't a coward i'll have to fight her children are these her kids or like her mom's children i'm wondering are these already her kids that she like gave birth to
I didn't realize they have like her she has an arena that I have to do as well this sucks but I hate are you fucking kidding me okay this is bad oh my god they're all synced up too they're actually synced okay never mind they're like fuck that
oh all right children here this time I need a heal too.
Oh god.
Oops.
I need a heal.
Okay, I got the heals at least.
Okay, never mind.
I need to remember, I need to know when she does that.
Are you serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
can you like remember yourself like less uh less harder can you like alter your memories so that you're less difficult to fight because it's literally her memory why did i don't even know this if she's just embellishing her own memory like how is she actually that hot back then?
I don't know that.
It's her own fucking memory.
She can alter it.
Yeah, can you remember yourself a few years older?
Like, maybe like a hundred years old?
Yeah, can't gaslight her to thinking she was fucking trash?
Oh my god, I'm gonna fight your goddamn children again.
Oh yeah, fuck this.
I'm taking you to the fire.
I can't be bothered.
Okay.
You
guys are so annoying.
Get back in here.
I think it's over, dragoons.
There we go.
Oh, I got four?
By now, I know.
Friend.
Jesus.
Oh, my God.
What do I...
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Friend.
I don't know how to dodge it.
Are you kidding me?
Ah!
I need to know the timing for the deflect.
I don't know the timing for the deflect.
Yeah, I need to figure out the timing.
I mistimed it.
Just get 10 masks, bro.
I can strike...
Oh, I can strike it?
Okay, now that I know that I can strike it.
Makes it a little easier.
Alright.
Just get all the upgrades, bro.
It's just that easy.
Okay, I'm just...
I got just so distracted because there's so many things on my screen.
Green!
Okay, I will say that was so frustrating to fight.
It's because you're red and they're red!
Oh my god.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Alright.
Oh my god, I should have to, I'm gonna try and focus for this.
this.
Are you serious?
Okay, that's five.
Friend.
Okay, I got the deflect.
Are you?
How?
What is your rage?
Oh my, it's not there.
Oh, I hate you.
I hate you.
Friend.
Her rage is nearly yes.
Oh my god, you're such a fucker
Oh my god, I hate you I need to learn to deflect it instead of jumping
I need to learn to Oh my god, I I jumped instead of reflecting I got punished Alright
What a beautiful dog
Don't rip that heart out of your body.
Do I...
Does it take my shells when I'm actually in this dream?
Or does it, like, reset after I die?
Yeah, I'm trying...
I keep jumping instead of hitting it.
Oh, it doesn't take my shell?
Oh, okay, so I can actually spam this.
That's good.
The only issue that I don't like about this is that I literally it's so hard to see the enemy because you're red and they're red it's it's actually it's so confusing
just gonna heal
I believe all right last one oh my gosh let me fucking use an ability
all right oh my god they're already dead And he's dead.
That's so fast.
Jam time!
That's not fair.
Oh my god.
It's not fair.
A fucking random ass air tap.
Oh my god.
There we go.
I need HP.
all right okay that run that's fine that's not fine oh my god her fucking body please please oh are you serious
okay i figured it out i figured her pattern out i figured it out i figured it out okay i'm locked in i know now i know what to do i'm so locked in I'm so locked in.
Bum, bum, bum, dog.
How many staggers does she have?
I'm locked in for real.
I can't see jack shit, by the way.
It's just all reds.
Oh my god, please.
and use this.
Surely you're one hit.
Thank you, guys.
Alright, I'm locked in for real.
I saw!
What the fuck?
Okay.
She, like, threw me off.
You don't understand.
Oh.
It's like, it's throwing me off, guys.
Okay.
I need to get used to hitting that.
I'm not hitting it.
Friend.
Okay.
Oh my god, second phase already?
I didn't even stagger her!
There we go.
I was gonna say, how did I get to a second phase?
Okay.
I'm trying to like...
I'm trying to focus so hard right now.
There you go.
Oh!
Stupid fucking dance!
Oh my god, I'm fucking worse!
Give me my silk!
I need silk!
Oh fuck!
Here you go.
I got it in time.
Okay.
No, you fucker!
You fucker!
We're so close!
I got the pattern!
I got hit!
I get hit!
It's a stupid...
Is there a stupid little saws?
I should have...
I should throw my own bone saws, honestly.
You know...
Oh my god.
I should have brought my bone saw.
I...
I should have thrown my own bone saw.
If she's gonna throw bone saws, I'll throw my own bone saw.
Alright, if we don't do it for this try, I'm getting out that bone saw.
I'll fucking bring that Oh my
god.
I'm just face tanking it.
Oh my god.
These guys are so fucking...
They're just so tanky!
That's it.
Get over here.
I'll believe.
Friends.
Alright, it's time.
Alright, get those free shots in.
She's too busy.
Dancing.
I need to learn to parry that shit.
I...
Okay.
My bad.
I'm focused.
No!
I still don't parry it!
Okay.
I don't!
That's it.
I'm freeing the bones up.
I was not focused.
But it changes here.
I'm grabbing the bone saw.
This time it'll be different.
Wait, this is...
Oops.
Oh, it's...
I mean, it's almost big.
She messed with the wrong bug.
It's bone saw time.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Alright, this time I'm focused.
For real.
No more brute force.
The sauce are coming out.
Alright, here we go.
Jesus Christ.
I was so used to the car.
Like, the cogs doing all the work.
For this fight.
Jesus.
Okay, I...
Both...
Saws might not be good against these guys.
Guys, I feel like maybe...
They're very good against maybe, like, the...
boss but not these guys not the least guys all
right this is it get over here Bones oh Bones stop Bones stop Bones stop Bones stop Bones stop there you go okay What?!
That should not have hit me.
Okay, I used- guys, I used up my bone saw.
I don't know.
I didn't think this through.
I might have accidentally used it all up.
I might have accidentally not think this through.
Alright.
There you go.
What the fuck?
Are you serious?
There you go.
Are you- oh my god, I didn't think she would.
The double hit.
God damn.
Not the double hit.
Get out of here!
Hit.
Oh my god, you're stupid.
Oh no.
screaming she mad are you fucking okay I got it I got the replay oh I thought she was gonna run it looked like I'll run that was my high ground
oh it was so close it was so close I'm so sad It was such a close one too.
I oh she fucked the she fucking it got me She swapped up her pattern.
She switched it up What if you run infinite sobbing?
She swatched she switched it up
All right I didn't know cog, the cog bugs, the cog bugs was actually really good for this part though.
I don't know about shit.
I feel like I just swapped it back.
That's for that particular section.
Wait, oh my god, the fucking snipe.
Oh my god, he's so far up in the sky.
That's not fair, that should have hit.
That should have counted as the deflex skill.
Oh my god, his badass body touched me.
There we go.
Alright, I wait, and then I do this.
Bonesaw!
There we go.
it works oh
no i didn't mean to do that oh my god get off of me
jesus christ
i'm so pleased thank you ma'am just don't jump
yeah i'm focusing so high okay now i'm focusing so high Now I'm focusing.
Ren.
Oh.
That's unlucky.
Yeah.
There you go.
Oh my god, she comboed me.
She's so smart.
It's like she's the queen of this queen or something.
Okay.
I'm locked.
I'm trying to lock in right now.
Okay, we have one more lay.
Oh my god.
It's that move.
That fucks with me the most.
Ow!
I shouldn't have done that.
Oh!
Alright, we're swapping the sauce.
Guys, the sauce might not be it.
It might not be the strat.
I'm just gonna use the bug.
The cog bug.
just to clean up in the beginning.
Uh, what do you mean infinite?
God, the cog flies.
No more.
No more saws.
I'm just gonna use this to get rid of the, to get rid of the bugs in the, in the beginning, though.
Oh, wait, I didn't want to talk to you.
I want to kill you.
Oh.
I could use Harpoon more, you're right.
I feel like distance is not the problem.
It's literally sometimes she like fucking swaps up her pattern.
That messes with me.
Her pattern sometimes messes with me.
Oh Yeah, no, this is a lot faster.
We're gonna do this.
Yeah, you guys heard that cleanup crew.
The cleanup crew is here.
Oh, the cleanup crew is dead.
There we go.
Fine.
He's almost dead.
Yay!
my god are you fucking kidding me oh my god just fucking slammed into her i slammed into her booty
accidentally i can't help it i i can't help it are you serious
she fucking i wish she does a 12 dash i don't know her the hips don't lie okay, okay that's it, I'm hyper focused no more yap, that's enough you've had your fun
I'm done playing with you
I'm done I'm locking in now I'm done letting you dance
okay There we go.
All right, I'm locking in, for real.
No more dancing for her.
What the fuck?
Where did they come from?
He's gonna steal now.
Oh, nice.
I was gonna say, I just steal.
There's no way.
Okay.
There we go.
All right, locking in.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Locking in for real this time.
For real.
I know I said that before.
But this time I'm for real.
Are you serious?
Stupid.
Stupid fucking booty.
There you go.
Friend.
Oh my god.
You think she was gonna twirl?
Are you...
Okay, that's fine.
I was trying to heal!
Okay.
You know what I said?
I was locking in for real.
This time I'm locking in for real.
This time.
No more greed.
I'm greeting.
Okay.
This time for real.
I kept running into her ass.
I can't help it.
This is how it's been a pattern.
Every time.
Every time they got the booty.
It can't resist.
She do be.
She do be had the booty.
No more greed for real.
Clean up crew.
Can you really blame me?
She knows she has it, too.
She knows she's got it.
Okay.
Oh, did you break already?
I literally just got to this fight.
Alright.
I'll get closer so you can do more damage.
Oh, wait.
She went this way.
Ah, fucking course.
I need to stop getting hit by that by Ken.
help it that you can't help it
oh she lands on me
okay i need i know i still i said that i need to like learn to parry that i can't help oh my god i always forget to
all right heal
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Alright.
The run.
Oh, fucking, of course you do that.
I don't deflect.
That's like my hubris right now.
I keep forgetting to deflect.
I just jump instead because I feel like it'd be easy.
But it's not easier.
It's not easier.
It's not easier, but I can't help it.
All right, this is fine.
This is fine.
I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in.
All right.
Full focus.
Okay, why did you throw that?
Friend.
There you go.
Alright, get in here.
There you
go.
Three.
Four!
Oh, it's just three of you.
Whole focus!
Oh, my god.
Okay.
I swear I'm focusing, it's just, I don't know.
Tokyo, are you sure?
I don't know anymore.
I...
Okay, I might not have been focusing.
Okay, I'm giving me a chance to heal.
Oh my gosh.
Fucker.
Okay.
There we go.
Friend.
Oh, fucking course she does the double.
Okay.
Oh my god, he does the spin.
I couldn't get out of the spin.
Why do you remember yourself like this?
Why can't you remember yourself weaker?
What a flatter ass Okay Alright Alright Alright that's it That's it No more I miss this nice guy She knew she was a bad
She remembers how peaked she is Yeah peaked in fucking high school
Oh my god Oh my god Throwing ass shit.
These are so annoying.
That's five.
Oh, and a critical.
I'll take those.
Alright, four of you.
We go in.
Oh my god, like you slam her once and you die.
Alright.
I couldn't go anywhere.
Please don't.
Please don't hit me.
Okay.
Oh my god.
That's when I need to deflect that.
Don't jump.
Oh.
That's fine.
I don't want to use my abilities because like I'm...
Oh my god.
I know I should.
Oh.
Oh, I jumped that too.
Are you serious?
What the fuck was that?
Alright.
Okay, I think I could do that.
Oh, focus now.
Oh.
Oh my god, you bitch!
Friend!
Ah.
Okay, phase three.
All right.
More twirling now.
There we go.
Oh my god, fuck the course you do, that's wild!
That's all you know how to, that's all you know how to do!
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I'm fucked.
I'm so fucked.
Please, let me heal.
Yes.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Ah, it doesn't matter!
I'm so close.
I'm the most locked in I've ever been.
Oh my god, it is the most locked in.
I even parried.
I even parried the dog.
I'm beginning to believe.
Oh, she's just that good.
Don't keep locking.
Sally, give us super chat.
Thank you.
I'm believing.
She can bleed.
I know she can bleed now.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right.
Jesus, I did not mean to do that please let me hit you it'll be so cool if they let me hit you like one time you know all right all right all right just keep smashing
goddamn range the range sometimes on these
But...
Okay.
Oh.
I'm greedy for that.
That was my bad.
That was so greedy.
I like forgot the range.
Oh my god!
A bullshit rage sometimes!
I hate you!
Okay.
okay nice she backed up she's keeping me cornered but that's okay it's not but like what the can I do about it like okay
oh my god fucking course are you serious fuck off okay oh my god I was actually that was actually a misinput
I should have reflected that.
I was trying to run right and actually ran left.
My fingers were too fast.
Look, I'm deflecting now.
I'm deflecting.
I'm deflecting now at least.
I learn.
I'm learning.
Alright.
Here we go.
Back to hell, I guess.
Get over here.
I'll kill your children over and over and over and over again.
Oh my god.
I just can't see sometimes.
That's like the worst part.
It's just...
It's just so much clutter.
All right,
he has to come down, right?
Nope.
Just do that downward smash.
There you go.
All right, the three of you.
All right, here you go.
I feel like I always get so close.
Oh my god.
all right what does oh I thought I would hit that sometimes I feel like I hit it but I don't oh I'm I'm not paying playing I'm greedy now I'm getting greedy that's bad no more greed no more greed no more greed don't stop reading stop greeting yeah and you stop greeting
she jumps up she okay oh i'm greeting i'm greeting i'm greeting i'm greeting okay be patient be patient be aggressive but be patient be aggressive but be patient oh
Okay, okay.
Be aggressive and be patient.
I can't help it.
I just...
I just want to beat her up.
I can't help it.
I just...
I just want to put a white shirt on.
Just...
Get her out of here.
I gotta stop greeting.
Alright.
I will greet for these guys.
Because these guys fucking don't matter.
But these guys don't matter in the long run, so I'm fine with greeting these guys.
Also heal real quick too.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I need to know when she arches her back, like, what?
That was not fair.
Okay.
Get out of here.
This is my spot!
There we go.
Okay, I can get a few...
Oh no!
Friend!
Really?
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
That's doing so well too.
Okay, I can do a heal here.
Oh my gosh, she throws it twice!
You're hot!
Unlucky.
Oh.
Eh.
No, I wanted...
I wanted to grab.
Oh my god.
Fucking, of course!
Let me hit you!
Okay.
Oh, I thought I hit...
Oh my god.
I don't think I'm gonna survive this area.
Oh, I'm literally one hit!
Literally one... I can't.
I'm gonna... Oh, I can't use deflect.
Deflect is like too risky.
I feel that.
I'm gonna... It's too risky to do deflect.
I'm gonna fucking use...
I'm gonna grab the...
I'm gonna grab the other one.
it's just too risky to use I never use it to because I'm like I'm like trying to save for it here oh all right it's time to play I'll keep playing this song till you're dead
um no all
right at least like I I don't need a, I'm not wasting shells for using cogs.
Thank God.
In my dream, they don't matter.
Or in her dream, it don't matter.
I'm a dream invader.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Where did he come?
I thought he was dead.
I was like, where did he come from?
Nope.
Wait.
Alright.
Oh, I can heal now.
Oh, I should have healed.
I should have healed.
Alright.
I think I can use this.
Jesus Christ.
I just got enough silk.
Oh my god.
I don't know if I wasted that.
Come on.
Locking in right now.
Don't jump.
Nice.
Are you sick?
Oh my god, you had to jump!
I'm fucking of course.
Bitch.
My free hits.
Give me my free hits!
Okay, here we go.
Friend!
Oh my god.
Are you- My silk right here?
I hate her.
I'm so glad she's not beautiful anymore.
I'm glad you lost your beauty.
I just stood there.
I just...
I...
The Sarah...
Whoa!
Damn it.
I can't use a suit.
Okay, I might have thrown that one.
I just think I was like, I'm glad you're not beautiful anymore.
You lost your beauty.
Now look at you.
Is there this fucker?
Okay, okay.
Eventually I'll start locking in.
I think this is it.
This is when, this is where it happens.
Oh my god.
If I, you're so fast.
I could grab this in.
What the fuck?
How did that hit me?
Oh, I got hit in too.
Why was she there?
Oh my god.
I hit two crits and I'm gonna waste that shit.
You know it.
Okay.
Oh.
How did two crits and she still doesn't have a stagger yet?
What?
There we go.
I'm gonna say.
No fucking way.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh my god, I didn't think she was gonna use that.
I'm gonna get full HP right now, just in case.
Yeah, I fucking knew it.
There we go.
Oh!
Are you...
Okay, I got healed.
Are you serious?
That was so uncalled for.
Oh my god, I hate you!
I hate you!
Please don't drop, please don't drop.
okay
are you fucking there we go we did do it oh i did it i only
got one stagger how we hunted how we sang my children i saw you glorious i thought i just got one stagger i didn't think i didn't think i got it oh thank god two crits i got two crits there and now she's dead
oh stagger is an hp oriented it's so like it like threw me off because i thought like like i didn't i it's i was just like just one stagger so i thought she had a lot more hp stagger based on his not damage so crit help oh so crits actually i was like oh my god two This is it.
This is it.
Two crits.
Gonna fucking clutch this for me.
Alright.
I was like, how do I do this yet?
It's been so long since I called the little guys.
Why do we go to Graymoor?
What do I get out of Graymoor?
Chat.
What do I get?
Where is this?
technically more fun is it really okay but like do i get anything out of it
yo so my precious disappeared please chase down the thief and recover oh wait i can grab another mask an extra heart i mean i like extra heart all right but first i want to grab an extra mask
That's like, far afields.
Where the fuck?
Risk, no bunny bugs, never factor.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Which one gives me a heart?
The mask?
Where the fuck?
The hidden hunter one?
This one, right?
Between deep docks and...
Farfields.
Where the fuck is that?
Alright, guys.
I need an extra mask, Bruce.
Between deep docks and farfields.
Where is that?
Here?
Where is that area?
Is the area it's just in?
Oh.
Where the Sprint Master is?
So here.
Wait, I don't remember where he lived.
It was somewhere here.
Where the fuck did that guy live and like it was like here somewhere i don't even remember
like here okay we'll go grab that and then
far right
where we go down oh here there it is oh my god why did i keep oh wait i have to grab congratulations on defeating aunt queen shakira adoki herpes the the not Not indeed lies!
Okay.
Um... Oh, it was from the bell tower.
Alright.
There's an easier one if you go left from Farfields?
Where?
Here?
Where's the easier mask?
TP to Farfields?
I want an easy mask.
I like it when it's easier.
Because I just need one mask, right?
I just need one mask anyway to get help upgrade.
Bam!
Thank you, my five!
Get the ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Right on the bench.
Oh, here!
I didn't go here.
Maybe I should have.
What the fuck?
What the fuck was monkeying?
Dark, attendant, home wheel.
What is that?
I got the cross summons.
I don't even know what this is.
Horizon!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, hello, Doki.
First stream, but long time fine.
Just wanted to pop in.
Uh, say that the amount of dopamine you're unhinged to getting produced is solely responsible for my continued existence.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you've enjoyed the stream.
Alright, well, do whatever the fuck they want me to do after I get my mask.
first.
Oh my god.
Bro, I got jury duty?
It's time.
I have to do jury duty, guys.
Give me a sec.
I've been summoned.
Oh no.
The boy got him.
Okay, that means the boy thing is here.
But are you sick?
here.
Oh, we gotta go this way.
What the?
Oh, that was fucked up.
I don't even know what to do with all these rosaries.
I'm fucking... Oh my god, I was gonna say, I swear to... I'm gonna... I'm bringing these guys along.
I don't trust myself.
All right, so we're in a little bit of a small predicament.
Oh, no.
Okay, thank God.
Never punished.
Thank God.
How am I supposed to go?
Okay.
Okay, it's fine.
There's a bench near me anyway.
Oh my God, it's fine.
near me anyway okay
maybe i shouldn't have summoned you guys it's not helping when it's red on red i gotta say it okay
there you go i landed all
right abago is this are you where the fuck did he come from is it here wait are you serious
I got confused I got so confused I thought I thought I made it oh my god I'm gonna die here aren't that
all right at least at least now I know that's evil okay
now that there's less screen clutter Wow, it looks...
Wow, it got a lot easier!
Oh my, okay, I got my silk back.
It's like...
The less screen clutter, the easier it looks.
The easier is to see the screen.
Who would have thought?
How the fuck is this?
Oh, money.
That's what it is.
Money.
All right.
I guess this is time to go fight an arena.
What?
Oh, this is why I have to track.
Let me watch this.
Wait, is this?
What is this?
Yeah?
Where's the tracker going?
Oh, there it is.
I don't even know what I'm tracking.
I was doing something else.
Oh, is this the quest I was supposed to do?
Oh my god, please.
Alright, the mask quest.
In this way.
Oh, I'm back here.
Wait, why the fuck did I have to do...
Oh my god, did I...
What is that?
What?
I thought I was supposed to do the...
Oh no, I lost the tracks.
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Okay.
I assume it's here.
Yeah, I thought it was an easier mask.
Oh, it's down.
I lost the tracks.
I'm just going with the flow now.
I- I lost it.
Where is it?
Oh, sit bench?
Okay.
Okay, I'll go sit on the bench.
Whee!
Is
it here?
Wait.
Here's at the three-way junction.
Below this...
Here?
This way?
Back up and left?
Oh wait, let's go right.
Okay.
It's fine.
What's he gonna do?
Fucking kill me?
Please don't.
Yeah?
Wait, no.
I'm a little worried that there's no tracks.
Oh, there it is.
Whoa!
all right it's time we're the outcast oh my god okay that's fine jesus christ okay oh that's oh he's the guy that's been putting the goddamn traps it was him the jesus christ this guy okay now i understand oh my god Are you... Where did he come from?
Alright.
Oh, wrong one.
It was him on the lion's grip.
You're the goddamn outcast.
Like, what killed me?
The goddamn dirt?
That's... I'm so fucking weak, man.
Even dirt kills me.
Alright, for rally.
What's down here?
Alright, our final stand.
I accidentally healed.
Okay, never mind.
That's awkward.
Oh, that is so awkward.
Whoops.
Oh my god, when he comes down, He also hurts me.
I need just too much stuff on my screen.
It's just too much.
I can't focus.
It's my hubris.
Screen clutter.
It's always a screen clutter.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know.
Screen 2 clutter, I can't see!
Oh my god, that should not have hit me.
Oh, wait, now he uses a new move.
I've never seen that move before.
Are you serious?
I'm stuck in this hellhole.
Alright.
What the fuck?!
That's five.
I need to get this guy out of here.
There we go.
Friend.
Oh.
New move?
Oh, the new move is he throws more traps.
Very cool move.
Oh my god, you fucking bitch.
You're nice.
Oh my god, please, I'm in my own fight.
We'll talk later.
Please, stop screaming.
I'm in my own fucking war right now.
There we go.
We did it.
Oh, does that work?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, yeah, there's only a taxidermy.
Shit going on here.
Fool me once.
Oh, is that the mask?
Grass stuff.
It's like a little trophy case.
He's like a... Yeah, he's like a serial killer basement.
Yeah, I was thinking that.
It's literally a serial...
Like, how do you even get these guys?
These guys don't even live here!
Wait, that's it?
There's some spot for me here.
Oh, wait, I can feel it.
Alas.
The heart.
Come to me.
Pell, pray.
Oh, I guess.
I'll never know.
Alright.
At least I still have some silk left of this.
I should get a mask now, right?
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, read his journal.
What does his journal say?
What does it say about this freak?
He tracks and hunts.
It should have been obvious from the start.
This old hunter saw to drop me in.
him to test himself so brutally.
The answer I suspect I shall never know.
Oh, he is like the fucking predator.
Alright.
He was the goddamn predator.
Okay, now I should have enough masks now.
So yeah, we don't need those upgrades.
I just want my Oh, my mask upgraded.
Wish granted.
Yay!
Yippee!
Okay.
So apparently...
Do I want to kill...
The last...
The last lover of the...
The gay couple.
Or do I leave him...
Alive.
so that he can live knowing that he lost the love of his life and that he'll never find a love just like him and let's live a long life knowing he'll be alone forever oh yeah sorry i had to go jury duty sorry he's hurting yes but should i leave him to suffer sorry guys i gotta go jury duty i forgot about that.
That one's actually much more important.
Where is jury duty?
Am I not here?
Where exactly is jury duty?
Well, alright.
I don't know.
What are you saying?
I've never been to jury duty.
They've never called for me.
Or maybe they haven't.
I'll call majority and i just never checked my mail
far right of graymore and what are you gonna do arrest me i think you might actually wait what oh hey no ha ha oh there he is ritala
there we go yeah
well met sister though the beastly sit us finally slain so the lands caught beneath it suffer the evas long done by the cursed place are sunk into kingdom's very foundation and now they rise up as a black sickness this darkness is a curse deadlier than the haunting a forest far below that will consume all if given the opportunity just so a wild witness still stock these lands our horn lands shall not rest all right it's cool all right i gotta go to jury duty now fucking call for me i guess it's all the way to that what sir i need to go to jury duty guys i don't have time for this
i actually don't have time for this
Oh, I thought they would get closer, but I guess not.
Fuck me.
Oh, friend.
Oh, these guys are so annoying.
They just kept coming up!
Oh, I'm all the way here.
Oh, I thought that.
I forgot to sit at a bench.
Eita!
I didn't realize I missed that bench.
But I go back to the bar.
Wait, actually I can't make it to the bar.
I just realized.
I just realized they're blocking the bar.
Oh my god.
I did not mean to fucking take that.
Alright, me and one Dragoon can't be that bad.
You got this.
You and I!
These are the guys I'm worried about.
Serious?
Are you serious?
He interrupts me twice?
Oh my god.
Okay, I can still heal.
Nice, I just got the heal.
I'll take those.
Oh, he's just one.
Please!
No!
Oh my god, that's so close.
Knock, knock!
I'm still gonna die here, aren't I?
Oh no, they're still at bar.
Just in time.
Oh, far right.
It works, it works.
I'm all about the faith.
I'm here to do efficiency here.
Jesus Christ.
It's all about the efficiency.
Bird arena.
What the fuck is the bird arena?
Oh, it's all the way to the far right.
Is it here?
I might go sit on the bench first.
What did I do wrong, anyway?
I don't understand.
What did I deserve to be summoned for jury duty?
Other than committing, like, several murders.
I don't understand.
Bird crimes.
Okay, but what bird crimes?
Hello, I'm here.
Oh my god, it actually is jury duty.
I hear them.
Wait, where are they?
Oh, down?
I hear all of them.
Oh, hello.
Hello?
You guys called for me?
Hi.
Hello.
Oh, whoa.
The court of cross.
Oh, shit.
Hey, what happened to my right for a lawyer?
I thought I have a right to a law, to attorney.
What?
What happened?
Where's my trainee?
I get judged.
Oh my god, I can't believe I missed everything.
Are you not gonna get tired and land?
There we go.
Trial, like...
Grab this and then here.
The bird you kill was your lawyer.
How the fuck was I supposed to know he was my lawyer?
He stabbed me first.
Friend.
Oh my god, I gotta fight the judge.
Crawfether.
What's he doing?
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's what he was doing.
okay friend oh my god fuck of course he summons things they all do
okay I want to get rid of this guy first all right nice are you seriously Ashley shimmy that way that fucker okay friend oh my god he's wearing a helmet I can't pogo him.
Okay.
Oh my god, they actually wear helmets.
They're like, no pogo allowed.
There we go.
Alright, I killed a judge.
Now there's no laws.
No more laws in bird world.
Promimento.
Bro, I just get a fucking memory.
That's it?
This is a lawless land now.
It's better to be a crawbell.
Okay, I was gonna say.
What is a crawbell?
What the fuck is a crawbell?
It's not here?
Where does it go?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, my God.
It's just for my house that I don't even go to.
I just live on the streets.
I have a...
I choose to be homeless.
It's just like...
For extra money.
But I don't even need extra money.
I bought everything I need here.
Wait.
You think they can?
They're like...
They're in the water.
I summoned them in the fucking water.
They come through here?
Yeah, they can.
Okay.
Wait, why red?
It's too late.
Whoa, too late.
Guess we're never going back.
Oops.
What do I need at right side?
For the optional area or bone borough to finish?
Oh, I love it.
Literally, I missed the...
I missed the prince.
Was he all the way to the right?
Was he actually there?
Oh, what?
Why would I want him to suffer?
I don't... You know?
Like...
Oh my god, they consumed the rat.
Just like...
Isn't it better that he gets to live a long life knowing that the love of his life is dead and he has to die alone?
I feel like that's better.
he has suffered and no one has suffered enough okay where is he
like me killing him basically ends the suffering like that's no fun I just think that's not as fun the yaoi should stay doomed
I feel like he wants to die That's the thing.
You guys are like, oh, but like you can make it more... No, he wants to die.
So it's like, what's the point?
I'd rather murder someone that still has, like, still has the will to live.
Because that makes it more fun.
Yeah, I don't want to reunite them in heaven.
Why would I reunite them?
What the fuck?
All right, where is he?
The fuck is this?
There's no such thing as fuck Evan.
Okay, now now that that at least I didn't say that It's like it's like when you know like how um people would be like sweetie your dog's not gonna go ahead dogs Don't go to heaven You know like some parents would say that to their kids they're like I'm silly,
I'm silly kid.
Your dog's not gonna go to heaven because they can't.
No, the cave's not open.
But all dogs, oh, you're right, it's cats.
Cats don't go to heaven.
Oh, I have to talk to him in the Citadel.
Well, I guess he'll never, I guess he doesn't get to die.
Yeah, the cave's not open.
you guys are talking about.
I assume it's this cave.
It's not open.
Yes, they do!
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, I have to go here.
I didn't even talk to that guy.
Ever since, like, I freed him from his prison.
I never talked to him again.
Where we go?
Oh, we have to go...
Oh, yeah, we gotta go to Masquerado.
Born Barrow.
Boom bottom.
Time to do the ritual.
Just like how cats don't go to heaven.
Bugs don't go to heaven, too.
That's funny.
I just kid these guys just for the sake of it.
Oh, my God.
My money that I don't even use.
There you go.
Goink.
Did I missed it?
No, it's over here.
Alright, do your stupid ritual.
I'm here now.
I found the well in the hidden chambers beyond.
The power that remained on space I've taken up for myself.
Found yourself a new nature, I?
And from the shells of our ancestors, no less.
Oh, there's many who've called these lands their own.
You make it seem so simple, like strength sucked up in a world of silk.
We called you a thief.
Old one and cool for the taken.
But it's all coming down soon and we can't stop it.
If there's an advantage in your act that might see these caves safe, then it's better you make your claim.
Would I not do this thing?
Fucking do your thing.
Man, I got the hearts.
Hmm.
It is time, shamans.
I have the hearts.
Enough as requested.
Enough to build your spells, yes?
I were ready.
Still, it's a sad set you're holding there.
What strength such as few shall ever know?
And all about that burn for fire looms saving.
I'll warn ye old one.
This first part might not be pleasant, but we'll get you in there, deep as needed.
Now, you've only...
You've only got yourself for what comes after.
Lay up on the dice, and we'll begin.
Alright.
That's it.
Do your thing.
Oh my god.
I'm consuming the heart.
What the fuck is going on?
What the fuck happened?
I have three hearts.
I have four hearts now.
Oh my god, I can never die.
I'm going to bug it.
Hey, there's no bug.
Oops.
I saw.
Okay, look.
How was I supposed to know?
I saw a hole and I assume I had to go in the hole.
Oh, I'm...
Oh.
Wait, this is a...
This is a...
The hunter, Chris.
Yeah, it's a depot, Chris.
Every hole is a goal!
Oh yeah, it's the weavers.
Oh, it flew me!
I'm a little baby!
I'm so- Oh, look at- am I- Wait, so this isn't a mask?
It's my actual head?
Child, show it, spend it, as only we can teach.
I thought that was like, I thought it was a mask.
Prove yourself more weaver than worm.
Yeah.
I'm doing it.
Oh shit, wait, am I killing them?
Am I using your silk to make my fucking dress?
May I kill them?
Oh, it is a mask, but it's just really small.
Yeah, I consume them.
Look at that.
Hit purity.
That's all I have to do.
I just gotta consume them.
Oh, goodbye.
Look, I haven't done parkour with this crest in a long time.
I use baby mode.
Oh.
I go down?
I'm not worried about going down.
Oh, I just go straight down.
But, um, it's my three hearts.
Or four hearts.
Oh, what?
Oh, it's a trap station.
Okay, it apparently doesn't work either.
Okay.
Oh, I'm back.
I'm here.
Oh I remember this here.
This one like When I had trust issues Yeah, it's deep nest Oh, this is my mom.
I don't remember her because she fucking gave birth.
She put me up and then fucking went to sleep He's horror ignore them daddy their whispers greater grander weaver guardian queen These are their desires not your own own.
It's certainly not mine.
Only if you resist them, you might see it.
Another hope beyond.
But to call these words in time so far, will you even remember me, child?
Could you?
A mother before the mask.
Before I lay forever in duty.
Oh, I'm so cute.
Look at me.
I'm so tiny.
and never woke up.
And that's how I got mommy issues.
See, Lace?
You're not so special.
Why she's so cute when a baby?
I actually did not need to do the party for this.
Whoops.
Goodbye.
Alright, down I go to another memory.
I assume I had like three memories because I found three hearts.
Oh, it's the bees net.
Oh, I'm gonna talk to the queen?
She was like my trainer or something?
Must be.
She was like my coach.
It's a hive, yeah.
Oh, bye.
I slowly flowed down.
Yeah, my second mom, who also died.
My bee mom.
Oh, ha!
Good,
better.
But still you will need to be faster.
In time, they will come for you.
Those who fear your nature and those seeking to claim it.
To survive our world, you must learn to sing.
Swift and sudden.
Oh, goodbye.
And then she died.
And that's where I got my second mommy issues.
See, you're not so special, Liz.
Like, boo-hoo.
My mother didn't love you.
My mother fucking went to sleep and never came back.
And my second mother, I don't know.
She just grew bigger and then died.
I don't fucking know how she died.
I actually don't know how the fuck did the queen with the bee die?
Like, what happened to her?
I'm in the white palace, yeah.
She grew bigger and then just died.
Oh, that's evil.
Making me parkour?
That's fucking evil.
I'm just gonna glide through this.
Okay.
Oh, down I go.
Another memory.
I have three hearts.
Oh, my third mom.
She didn't love me.
Because I wasn't her real daughter.
I was a...
I was a bastard, child.
Alas, spider's child.
For always, you'll think us harsh.
You'll think us uncaring.
Unrepentant.
And so we must seem, for such it's the cost of our wish.
You're wrong, lady.
I know the wish and the price to achieve it.
And now across these many ages, I have only come to know it better.
Strength in mind, in care, in claw.
Strength in enough that I may live to see a world better than our own, or to craft the world as I desire.
That was the wish of my mother, of my mentor, and of you.
Indeed, Spider, so much.
much pain you must pass to speak i hope so simply for her you become who knows clear our desire has been full the darkness beneath our house i will show you the gift oh she has the flower this is the flower witness the first light the only means we possess to resist that void of which our family is forever linked reach for a child grow strong rest it from this remembrance burn yourself free from our sad fate.
Yay!
I got the flower.
I got the ever bloom.
Fragile flower taking from a deep and distant memory.
I did it, guys!
Look!
Look, everyone!
I got the flower!
Guys!
Guys?
Oh, that's awkward.
Guys, look, guys, I got some flowers.
It was...
They were already dead when I got here.
Yeah, they went to go visit the snow farm, right?
From snow farm downstate.
What happened?
Oh, was there a crest?
Oh, wait, it's a map.
Not the snow farm.
We already have the mage quest.
Uh, crest.
We already have it.
Do I have enough for Eva?
I don't even know.
Yeah, I already got that shit, bro.
Do I even have enough, though, for Eva?
Probably not, I assume.
Alright, I mean, we could try.
Wait, I want to order food before...
My favorite restaurant...
There was a restaurant I wanted to order for a while.
And it closes at, like...
It closes at 11.
So I want to order it.
Wait, is this the supercomputer?
Where the fuck is she?
She's, like, over here.
Let me order food.
I've been craving this place for like three days, but I always miss it because of streaming.
Like it's been three days.
I was like been craving this place.
And then I miss it every time.
I sense it in you.
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
I'm ordering food.
I'm yum, yum, yum, yum.
Give me a sec, guys.
It's yum, yum, yum, yum.
order this too
let's see oh I really do I get that oh men oh carbonara udon I love that shit that shit's good as hell uh I'm getting carbonara udon I've been craving this shit and they had like they have skewers as well I've been craving skewers Like, Japanese skewers for a while.
Winita.
You guys can read this, right?
I'll let you guys read this wild order.
Oh, yeah, I don't think I...
Wait.
Nope, that's not what I wanted to do.
Oh, shit, I upgrade.
Nice.
I'm not here to read...
I'm not here to read out of it, but I still do it.
Okay.
Strike enemies become more.
Oh, okay, so my hunter crest got updated.
Nice.
I still do it.
I do it for you guys
That's me All right That is that's it.
Oh, okay All right, I ordered my food
Wait, does it give me I want to of where's the chopsticks all right whatever all right looks good yeah i don't have enough to me again all right yeah i got my food all right nice all right also i should find give me a sec i'm gonna disappear uh because i realized i forgot to set up my uh i wasn't jumping if you guys that because I forgot about that I forgot to boot that up all right now I can jump now it's over it's over I could jump now there you go we're good to go
all right I think I can complete this game today I'm pretty sure now we're fully immersed hello oh is it out here?
Wait, what am I doing?
Yeah, pick me up.
There you go.
Bro, they don't even need a player needle.
That's why I should kidnap their child.
Okay.
Uh, alright.
Where the fuck was that place?
This feels like it's been 20 years.
The abyss.
How do I get there?
Oh my god, okay, deep docks.
Right down, down.
Alright, we gotta go to the deep docks.
Alright, it's time.
It's the final countdown.
Let's go, time.
Oh my god, this is not my crest.
Oh, no, I...
Now, I definitely don't know where I am.
I...
Okay.
It's okay.
We're just gonna find the bench.
There was a bench here, I remember.
There it is.
I was like, wait a minute.
This doesn't seem to be the...
This is not the crest I use.
Alright, this should be fine.
And then we go down here.
Then we left.
It's okay, we don't need tools.
Where I'll come from.
Uh, this way.
Yeah, down I'll go.
Oh, don't keep these.
It's okay.
Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, there it is.
I was gonna say, oh, forgot about that.
Oops.
forgot about the um the lava how the fuck do I go back to hell then like here
I guess here right back to the bell here right the chair
do I have to talk to the bell man do I have to go back to the Forge daughter and talk to him?
Oh my god, this fucker.
Oh, he's already there?
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
He's already there.
I was gonna sit.
Like, did he go back to her?
Fucking sit.
Wait, I thought the machine broke.
Did he fix it?
Yeah, did he fix it again?
Oh, he fixed it.
Okay, I was gonna say, oh, he did fix it.
Nice.
All right, take me down.
Are you feeling mad enough to try and travel?
Best me up.
Oh, I have to talk to him.
Mark, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Love your stream of this game.
I watched your no-hit run against Savage Beast.
Fly to it and was amazed.
He made my life the hell he lived in.
This finale is my favorite part of the whole game.
All right.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
I thank you, thank.
you've been enjoying the stream so far.
I didn't think I was going to finish it today, but I already am at the last part anyway.
I see you survived somehow.
Thought the last plunge must have been your end.
It was not.
I survived the fall and managed a treacherous return.
But Diamond Bell's failure, the risk was clear to me.
The fault lies not with you.
I, as you say, this bell is old and time has a way of breaking things, even as fine porridge as this.
And see below, before it's failing up and working hard and improving the design, your long journey end up being a valuable test.
Good.
Now return path is long close to me, and your bell is now needed again.
Again?
Well, if you're game enough to try a second time, a shell shield's been fitted, and a bell's like new.
Better than you.
If you're planning on your descent, head down, holler, and I'll get you going.
All right, down I'll go.
all right i'm ready next via oh wait wait jk i'm ready for real he's like jk i was joking i'm actually ready at least he fixed it thank god
it's a good thing you fixed the bell
i don't know what game to play after i finish silk song because we're doing one series we're just focused on one series uh instead of like two that was crazy of me there's so many games i want to do so i'm like don't know which one i want to play next you find what flavor oh i'm i haven't uh replied back yet because uh i told my manager uh uh i apologize and said like i've been like super busy with everything and also i I had the business trip that I went,
I had to go to.
So, um, so I'm not replying back this week.
But we have, uh, my manager apologized for me.
Um, I told him to help me to, like, apologize to, like, her manager about it.
Because I was, like, sorry, I'm literally, like, I'm all over the place.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Alright, I'm alive.
Oh my god, I have to take that off.
Fucking, okay, wait.
Am I?
Okay, I'm alive.
It's okay.
I can...
I got distracted.
I plan on replying back and organizing the... and the organizing the shoe eating thing.
Jesus Christ.
He like blends in.
You're gray on gray.
Uh...
Soon, TM.
I literally have not been replying to any messages.
For like a week plus.
Where is my fucking... Oh, it's over here.
here.
How did it get all the way over there?
There was no way I traveled that far.
Well, I was like very overworked and burnt out.
So I wasn't like replying to anyone.
I asked my manager to like if there's like any business of emergency to let me know.
I was just so overworked and burnt out.
So I just didn't want to like socialize at all.
Yeah, so the New York trip really helped a lot.
It really reset myself a lot.
You think?
Hmm.
Maybe this time I can use deflect.
Oh, because I assume I'm fighting Lace, right?
I'll try.
It doesn't work.
I'll just...
I'll just, like...
use something else.
Child.
I hope that means to this end.
Let us meet one in the final time and quell this black ruin of our making.
Hello, Lace.
I'm gonna beat the shit out of you.
What are you hoping you'll find down there, Spider?
An alien child?
And a silk star beast?
And so, I'm afraid.
We may slowly disappoint.
What waits below?
As me no longer.
You're not a...
Even if only you're shadow remains.
To release your mother's crypt, my blade will see it slain.
Then why hold?
Even this moment, surely terror has this unacclined your heart and heart.
Take the final plunge, Spider.
Join us in my drowning palace and let Oblivion swallow us all.
Oblivion may take, he is child.
My own life, I shall not sacrifice.
I survive the fury of your land.
I have borne in its Barbs and his blades, and I've seen wonder behind his danger.
But always, child, I mean, made a daughter of hollowness and a void below all things that darkness I will fear no longer.
All right.
Time to punch a child.
Down I'll go.
Oh, sorry.
Down I go for real.
Woo, yeah!
Santa stab a child!
Here I'll go.
Eh, my flower's working.
I would assume, like, you're like, oh, she's down there.
I just fucking go down there.
I didn't realize I had to fucking do another command.
Oh, no, my flower.
My flower, it's dying.
It's so fragile.
It's like getting eaten.
Like, nom nom.
yam yam by a butt grub.
Oh, oh, it's like the mom made a little silk cocoon.
I see.
Like, mom made a little silk cocoon to, like, um, to, like, protect her child.
Oh, hello.
Oh, there she is.
Hello.
Oh, there's the child.
Oh, she's been consumed by a boy.
Lost this.
Alright, time to get fucking beat up, I guess.
That hit nothing?
That's great.
That's actually crazy.
That actually hit nothing.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, I'm so confused.
I'm actually so confused.
Like, I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm looking at like I don't even know okay I got oh I got like so confused I was like what am I looking at it's just all black on my screen all right here we go again round two but can I skip this oh now go down even faster thank god like she was like okay we don't need this cutscene anymore like
Oh my god, I have to watch her fucking ascend from the pit
This is gonna take a while.
I'm not even I don't even know what oh my
Really I can tell this is gonna take a while Oh my god that happens she can do that
Okay I think Lace, like, I don't know.
Lace is like...
Lace is like fucking hard.
She's like the hardest one I've ever, like her iteration.
There's just something about it.
Really?
She does the jump?
Really Lace is really easy?
I had trouble with her second phase.
Her second face fucks with me.
I just hate to have to watch her ascend from the fucking tar.
Alright.
I just hate to have to watch this every time.
But Lace 2 was very difficult for me.
Alright, let me see if I can figure out her pattern.
I want to know when she...
Okay.
What?
Okay, that's bullshit.
Oh, I forgot to eat myself.
Give me a sec.
I'm just wondering if I should...
Really?
Oh, okay.
Okay, I was not expecting that.
Get Perry.
I want to use deflect, but I'm so scared.
Oh.
I'm just gonna...
Because I feel like I want to save my...
I want to save my silk for heals.
What?
Okay!
That's bullshit.
What?
Oh no.
Oh no!
Wait!
No, now you have Toho!
It's not fair!
I want Toho!
Why do I never get Toho powers?
Shit.
Oh my god, what the fuck am I fighting?
What?
I don't know what I'm fighting anymore.
What is this?
Oh my god, I don't know what is this.
friend okay
she comboed me oh my gosh she double comboed me
oh no I know this is not over this does not oh no I can tell I can tell she's coming back with more please give me yourself ma'am oh
Oh my god.
I'm so confused.
Oh, this is where I got.
Oh, woo!
Woo!
Oh!
I was one hit and I knew it was over.
I had one HP.
And I had no idea what was going to happen.
I got a phase two at least See bingo, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you Glad to see you attempt the finale, even though sometimes You get the memory of an orange, we still love you Great stream, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you, I'm glad you've been enjoying the stream I'm gonna grab myself real quick Lost Lace I like to think that like
I like to think like they got back up They're like, okay, it's reset time.
Like, the mom just got back up.
Oh, he went that way.
Okay.
I thought she was going to go a different direction.
That sucks.
I need to know when she does...
Oh, that's fine.
That's fine.
What?
Okay, come back.
Come on.
That was bullshit.
That was so bullshit.
Come on.
Oh, I hate that.
Friend.
Okay.
What?
I was not expecting that.
Okay.
She's at the jump.
Oh, she did the job.
I thought she was going to do the dash because it looked like the dash attack.
Just Venom lady is insane.
Okay.
I know I should use my deflect more, but I'm, like, worried about heals and stuff.
So I'm, like, paranoid about my heals.
Bro, I know you're good.
Bro, just you just wait there.
You don't need to fucking come back in the car.
You can avoid every time
Okay, I like try and use my dislike more Really
Okay, he got she got me she got me Nah, yeah, I hear
I'm gonna heal
There you go There you go.
Oh my god.
I hate that I hate that it doesn't matter about my deflec there Here you go.
Oh, you fucker I wanted to deflec.
Oh, I didn't mean to heal I was trying to deflect there that was an accident I actually didn't mean to heal
oh my god this fucker
oh there you go okay I'm like sorry I'm getting aware of her patterns more and more though I'm downloading her I might it might have the download might have got corrupted but I'm I'm downloading her.
I'm just downloading it again.
It got corrupted midway, but it's okay.
I find her.
It's nice that your mom's watching.
God, you're such a bitch.
I was complimenting you.
Woo!
Oh my God.
That's not what I wanted to do.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
My heal just in case.
Really?
That hits me?!
I'm backing up.
There you go.
Oh, nice crit.
I got crit.
I did that on purpose.
A fucking course.
Oh, my God.
Get me out of here.
You can see her.
Okay, I still have...
What?
That should not...
have hit me okay oh my god oh it's over one hp and a dream again oh no oh no it's one hp second phase one hp let's go
that's how i like it all right Pain.
Actual pain.
She's gonna hit me one time and it's over.
Okay.
I
almost got a healer out, too.
I felt it.
I felt it, too.
I was like, she's gonna do that arm stretchy thing, isn't she?
She read me like a book.
She wrote my Wikipedia.
Magic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, when she does that, that's the...
Oh my, get up that way here.
Whoa, where did she come from?
Fuck!
Okay, that's bullshit.
That was actually bullshit.
Oh my god, when she does that, I didn't know she...
There you go.
Ah, I jumped that too.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I Didn't have room I actually put my I actually put myself in the corner The download is Download is deleting itself.
I didn't have space in my hard drive.
Sorry.
I gotta delete some trash real quick I gotta delete some files my download couldn't be completed.
I ran out of hard drive space
What okay I thought I used my Okay, I'm gonna heal real quick then.
Again?
Okay.
I wasn't expecting her to do it again.
Okay, I'm gonna try and lock in.
Okay.
Oh my god, Rano's face.
I need to try not to get in the corner.
Oh, when she puts me in that corner.
It's bad.
It's so bad.
She just hits my... I just touch her head.
I just touch her head.
I...
That's it.
I'm fucking...
I'm bringing up the shards.
Alright.
I'm bringing you guys to the fight now.
That's it.
Yeah, as you're coming in.
You're gonna help me beat up a child.
You're gonna be part of the problem.
I don't have tax.
I've never got them.
Every time they're like, oh, you should use tax.
I was like, cool.
That would be cool if I have them.
Oh my god, the only issue is I can't see.
I'm like, how am I close for that?
All right, try not to get too close.
All right.
Woo!
Here we go.
Second phase.
Thank God I got crit.
Thank God.
All right, and then she falls down.
this is the first time i've had full hp for this fight i don't know i don't know how this is gonna go i never had that before this is a new experience oh my gosh oh my god and already i'm fucking it up i
don't like this fight jesus christ no this is a lot harder because it's so cluttered now like I can't see shit I literally I can't see shit like I can't see anything I
can't see anything let's fight sauce
Jesus Christ I can't see anything Oh no, now I'm running out of cock flies.
I can't see shit!
She's like blinds in the background because she's also black!
I'm in the void and she's also the void!
It's black, I'm black, I'm black!
Save the cock flies for the end.
Never!
Oh my god.
Oops.
I still can't see you.
Alright.
Bye.
Oh god.
So, um, there's no more cocked eyes.
Surely that's fine, right?
Oh my god.
You should put me in the corner again.
There you go.
All right, I'll just do this.
Where am I?
All right, that's where I am.
I'm mad if only I saved them.
Never!
I never learned.
Learning from my mistakes, I flashed my head against a wall until it works that's the joki way that will always be the joki way
where the oh my god there she is where is she oh there she is
what that hits me
oh my god that was an accident
where is she going oh shit
Okay, I'm...
I've never seen that move before.
Alright.
Oh my god, please.
Jesus.
Oh my god, she's fucking me up, she's fucking me up.
Holy shit.
Where am I?
Oh my god.
Oh god, where is she?
No!
I didn't want a...
Oh my god.
Okay, I don't want my cock flies anymore.
Oh well.
Oh.
I was so close.
I literally I needed... I didn't think she would hit me back.
I should have hit her once and fucking healed.
Well, um, I don't want my cock flies.
anymore so just see a bit harder now.
No more talks like it.
Oh my god, where did you come from?
Okay, I guess I'll try and focus up.
I guess.
What the fuck?
Okay, I'm like, where did she come from?
Okay, friend.
Okay.
Jesus, I'm just gonna heal here.
Really?
And god, I got three hits there.
Oh my god, she put me in the corner.
Get me out of here!
Get me out!
Oh, really?
Friend.
Oh
Okay I didn't think she was gonna do that.
Oh, I didn't think she was gonna do that too!
I didn't think she was gonna do that as well!
The other guy was like wait she's gonna do that?
Oh, and then that?
Oh, and also that?
Okay, fuck, okay I didn't freak out any of those moves.
I unfortunately did not predict it.
Oh, no.
It's gonna...
Oh, fuck!
Whoop.
I may or may not have jumped a little too early.
That is what you call my bad.
Whoopsie.
Oh, my God.
Friend.
Okay.
Oh, I need she does that.
Oh, the tentacle!
What?
You're on it.
She did an oopsie.
Okay, I'm big.
I'm slowly.
I'm understanding.
It's all coming together.
Everything is coming together right now.
Okay.
I know I said that before, but For sure, for real.
This time.
I'm locking in.
For real, this time.
Okay, after this.
Oh, shit.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you?
Ah, she defeated in front of me.
Okay, okay.
You know what?
I said, I'm locking in for this.
I'm locking in for real.
I'm locked.
This time.
Okay, focus.
No, no, no, yeah, no,
yeah.
I hate this.
I hate that the watcher fucking emerge from that boy.
And then hearing her scream, like, just fight me.
I, we've done this already.
Just, I'm okay.
Let's just fight.
We just want to fight.
Like, bro, I get it.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I don't want to put too much in the corner.
Alright.
Nice.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm gonna full heal for this, fuck it.
Really?
Oh my god, fucking course!
Alright.
Get healed.
Oh, fucking of course she does that.
Teal.
I won't be full HP.
Oh!
There we go.
Her range is crazy.
Is this?
It's just so cluttered.
This part fucks with me so much because it's just too much clutter.
I can't see fucking oh okay that was just my mistake
oh she jumps there really
oh I try to jump away oh I can wall jump that oh my god that's smart I should just do that Sage one, I just feel like I got it.
Yeah.
I can't ignore it.
It's in my face.
I do a no-clutter when it's just there.
That's it.
That is how I'm bringing that now.
Okay.
Oh, I wanted to go to the...
I fucked it up.
All right, friend.
I was trying to jump that, but it didn't let me.
Okay.
Are you serious?
I'm fucking cursed.
You always see me to me.
I hate it when that happens.
There we go.
Friend.
Alright, I got some freebie hits.
Right there.
There you go.
Oh, my god.
Fuck off!
Friend!
God damn it.
I messed that up.
Really?
Oh, my god.
Teleports behind me.
There we go.
You're stupid.
And you have to watch your goddamn cutscene.
I- I have to watch your mom falling down.
Wait, is that his wallet?
Nah, that's too much.
Alright, there you go.
Stupid ass cutscene.
Oh my god, try to leave this area.
Friend.
Are you serious?
God damn it.
I'm so scared.
I'm so!
I
have reason to be scared.
Time.
Dive again.
Mirako again.
You're right to be scared.
Alright.
Oh no, yeah, no, yeah, no, yeah.
I keep yapping and that's where I start fucking up.
Okay, that was bozer!
That was bullshit!
Okay, no yapping.
Don't let her rage fake you!
Don't let her win!
Oh my god, I hate you so much.
Okay.
What the fuck was that move?
I've never seen you do that before.
Jesus Christ.
There you go.
There we go.
Oh, just be safe.
Got two crits, I know.
And now I'm gonna...
And now I'm gonna fuck it up.
Oh,
here they come.
Here they come.
Okay.
All right.
Lock in, lock in, lock in.
Are you...
Oh my god.
Where is she?
Okay.
God, the fucking pit.
A black who?
Not the black goo!
Okay, jump.
Oh!
Woo!
Oh shit, I hate that move so much.
Are you serious?
Where is she?
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's written.
Oh my god, please have mercy.
Oh my god.
This is it.
I'm dead.
It was so close.
She did not have mercy.
Oh.
I was so close there.
Oh my god.
That was the most locked in I've ever been.
Okay.
with a strap no i started yapping that's the strap okay oh my god you're kidding me are you okay
okay i messed up okay this is not good
okay guys i'm focused
Jesus, okay, thank God I had the dice.
Okay.
Pray.
There you go.
Okay.
Oh my god, that was an accident.
Pray.
okay there we go i'm trying to like i'm trying to like um oh i just know i'm not using my deflex it's just i'm too scared to use like my magic i feel like my i'm i need a heal i'm just too scared
i just keep wanting to save it for heals
okay oh my god that was my bad Oh shit Or oh oh oh
Okay Oh guys oh Oh guys What the stupid teleport
Jesus Christ Jesus Christ
Okay Really He go!
Right.
All right.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Okay, that was bullshit.
Oh my god, please tell me that's the last phase, please, please.
Oh my god, I had to do a double tap.
Please.
No, please.
No.
Oh god.
Is that it?
Did I do it?
Oh shit, okay.
I did it.
Do I play a song now?
Do I?
Oh my god.
We leave.
My people need me.
Oh my god, I told you I downloaded it!
I stilled my song!
Oh, okay, it didn't take as long as I thought it would.
I'm not gonna lie, with no tools and magic, like, just magic to heal.
I think I did pretty alright.
I did it.
I suck the song, guys.
Oh, good boy.
Who wants to give me a hug?
Oh, oh, bro!
Where were you?
Bros!
Where the fuck were you?
Why did you vouch for me, man?
I thought we...
I told you to vouch for me.
Telling the boy we're cool.
Oh, my God.
It's John Hollander.
It's my homie.
He told a boy that...
Yeah, now he told a boy that we chill.
They just did...
Yeah, after we fucking finished the job, they'd get the North Boy pulled up.
Bro was stuck in traffic.
I had to be, like, two hits like, during my other trip...
When I was that close, I had to be, like, one or two hits or some shit.
Because it didn't felt like I had to hit her that much in phase two.
why are you laughing your mom's fucking dead for real bro what the fuck is around you but she's crazy she's actually crazy she's like those like can you fix her
girls yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank you congrats on beating the game wait is this the epic bug Yuri everyone was talking about thank you for the super chat thank you thank you TEE pedo she's like she's definitely been as fuck, dude.
Guys, it's like, can you fix here?
Oh my god!
I did not think we were gonna finish.
We were finishing all the night.
I had I have two more thumbnails.
I made preparation.
Because I was like, oh, because you guys were like, it'll be two streams.
But like, I've got the three hearts so fast.
Like, I got it within, like, three, like, what was it?
Within, like, three to four hours?
So I was just like, oh, okay, like, I didn't believe I had, I actually had two more thumbnails I made in preparation for the next one but we did it I skipped a lot I know there was a lot of mini bosses that I didn't do because I didn't think there, I thought I had to do more like,
I thought there was like it was part of the pathway yeah apparently there was like a lot of side content that i didn't do but i beat the game i beat the game and that's all that matters yay i did it before my food got here too which is the best part it
was five bosses and that's it i missed trobe true trubio too nobody missed trubio you did awesome dorky congrats but man i'm gonna miss a dorky bug but if we ever have any other future bug games don't worry dorky bud will come back up Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
The reviews were in.
And his show got canceled.
Until DLC.
Yeah, until then maybe a new DLC comes out.
A Doki Bug will come back.
Did you know?
I've recently found this out recently.
But like, you know how Silk Song or like Silk Song and Hollow Knight are super popular in China?
And apparently like usually like people don't really do speed runs.
It's not.
But Hollow Knight and Silk Song.
It's like one of the few games that like people love doing speed runs of in Asia.
Wait, also need me to answer this.
It was my food.
I didn't want to say anything because it'd be weird.
Yeah, I was reading it.
That's why like a lot of the mods that you see actually originated from the Chinese modding side.
Like a lot of the skins, the skins, yeah, like Hollow Knight and Silk Side is like huge in China.
And a lot of the skins you see in Hollow Knight.
Night actually came from Chinese artists and coders, which is very interesting.
Odin, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, thank you, be ready in seven years for Hollow Night List.
Now, God of War Ragnarck, maybe?
I think you was super chat, thank you, thank you.
I don't know.
I don't know what to do for the next series to do.
I'm not sure what to do for my next series.
I mean, I have like two more days to figure this out.
I don't know what to...
Okay, I will do an extra stream tomorrow.
because I do have my sponsor stream tomorrow that's at 9 30 a.m.
uh that's at 9 30 a.m.
so I'll see you guys there tomorrow but I will do an extra stream on um on 78 that's pretty good 78 um for me skipping a lot of shit um yeah no I know good luck to both of us like that to you and me um i did not realize when i signed up for this uh they're like because it was like such a last minute sponsor literally we finalized everything today like um like not like yesterday night slash like i woke up at seven in the morning because my manager's called we have to finalize stuff for this sponsor um it's basically the new new pubg game um and uh and we finalize the sponsor like you're like oh you want to do it um because i was like oh fuck it um like it i spent a lot in new york so i bought a 250 million swaski thingy so uh so it's like a top down shooter so you know like a top down tactical shooter where you have to you know like the ones where you defuse and plant bombs like and then like you have to like like um reinforce like walls and stuff and you can breach walls it's those
type of games but it's top down instead of like first person shooter um um but yeah so like that's for tomorrow but i'll do another also do a bonus stream um on youtube i don't know what to play though i'm not sure yet what to play i'll figure that out later um i can't say what other games it's it's similar to because it's a sponsor uh but you understand you got you in chat you guys in chat understand what other games it's similar to but i can't say what games it's similar to um i enjoyed silk song a lot actually really i really like this type of game um it has been very fun um i definitely i enjoyed it a lot i felt like i could play this if um like i could play more of this um but i feel like we have to start a new series we gotta start a new series so whenever if a dlc comes along uh we'll go back into it maybe we'll do more of the other bosses too if a dlc comes along anyway guys thank you all for coming many thank you the super chat thank you thank you joki bug and the outro i miss
her already um we might have a new updated outro soon soonish uh with some new new outfits in it but yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank you Just, I don't know when it's gonna be done.
Factor, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Congratulations, my gamer chief.
So I guess our journey ends here, huh?
It's been a while, right?
Thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I literally didn't realize I was gonna finish this day.
I was gonna, like, make progress of it.
And then, like, you know, next year would be like, oh, finale.
But I thought it was, I thought I had a lot to do, but apparently not.
Apparently, apparently, it was, we were very close to the end.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna head off now.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
Oh, yeah, there's Laces Nita.
Congrats, Steel Soul, run next.
We're gonna literally die within an hour.
If I do Steel...
Have you not seen me face-tank with no regards to my life?
Fifth, bad.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I would be surprised if we last an hour on Steel Soul.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, Stay hydrated, posture check, get up, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.